Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier in der Garderobe der Käs und warten auf unseren großen Auftritt.
Der Saal ist voll. Aber wir wollen erst einmal ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen. Und zwar ist das ein Buch, auf das wir gekommen sind durch die Lektüre des Buchs von Branko Milanovic. Der hat das ja sehr gelobt. Dann habe ich mal nachgeschaut, was ist das überhaupt? The Meritocracy Trap, also die meritokratische Falle von Daniel Markovits. Und dann sehe ich dort gleich auf dem Cover von A Bold Brave Critique von Michael Sandel, dessen Buch wir ja auch sehr gelobt haben, dass uns wirklich die Augen geöffnet hat im Hinblick auf Leistungsgesellschaft und was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man von einem Gemeinwesen spricht und warum das das Ende des Gemeinwesens ist. So hat ja Michael Sandel sein Buch genannt, wenn man nur noch meritokratisch denkt. Und wir beschäftigen uns also dann noch einmal mit der meritokratischen Falle und mit der Meritokratie, weil die ja jetzt so vorherrschend geworden ist. Deshalb, weil wir diese Homopletie haben, von der Milanovic spricht. Das heißt, wir haben Menschen, die nicht einfach nur Vermögen haben und geerbt haben, sondern sie verdienen auch noch gleichzeitig sehr, sehr viel, sind also doppelte Elite und können sich damit auch gut imprägnieren und sagen, ja, aber wir haben doch was geleistet. Warum wollt ihr uns dann den Status mardig machen?
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Bei dem letzten Mal, als wir Sandel zum Thema hatten, war ja auch klar, das ist ein Buch, das beim Kanzler auf dem Nachttisch liegt. Auch deswegen haben wir es aufgegriffen. Und das war also eine bessere Zeit. Denn ich könnte mir vorstellen, egal was da drin steht, und wir wissen ja so ungefähr, in welche Richtung uns das Denken erweitert, dass wir es nur noch als Appell formulieren sollen, dass das mal auch bei Demerz mit im Klo rumliegen sollte, falls er da mal Zeit hat.
Es wird er aber nicht sein. Er wird es nicht gelesen haben. Davon können wir eigentlich fest ausgehen. Sag doch mal, was du heute Abend vorhast. Du hast ja eine Stunde vorbereitet, die ein bisschen anders ist als sonst.
Wir machen eine kleine Reise nach Quedlinburg. Keiner weiß, wo das ist, auch egal.
Wien.
Welches Wien? Was ist mit Wien gemeint? Also mir geht es auch darum, heute einen neuen Mindset zu pflanzen. Mindset ist ein Wort, das ist bei uns verschrien, zurecht. Aber wir haben heute Spezialpublikum. Wir haben heute Publikum und Publikum. Und wir müssen den Podcast heute, also ich meinen Teil, auch ein bisschen instrumentell verstehen. Hier sind Leute, die unser Schicksal in der Hand haben, Mainz zum Beispiel, Mainz nicht so. Und denen muss halt in Kürze mal was gesagt werden. Und von daher kommen wir heute nicht ganz um Mindset herum. Um uns darüber zu informieren, was ist jetzt zu tun, liebe SPD?
Und nicht nur bezogen auf Frankfurt. Das ist dein Beispiel, an dem du es aufmachst. Und Dortmund ist der andere Fall, über den du sprichst. Wir werden aber allgemein da sehen, wie eigentlich sich Kommunalpolitik verändern muss.
Ja, ich möchte, dass die Kommunalpolitik ein neues Mindset hat. Ich will keine weiteren Politiker, die in Berlin auf der Straße stehen und sich freuen, dass sie mal einen Termin beim Kanzler hatten. Sondern ich möchte das genau umgedreht. Ich möchte, dass der Kanzler drum bettelt, dort mal einen Termin zu haben. Und dieses Mindset muss man ausstrahlen. Das muss man haben. Das muss man üben. Und wir haben mit drei Jahren hier eine Oberbürgermeisterwahl. Aber im März, wir werden also bilanz zu heute schon im nächsten Live-Salon ziehen, ist eine Kommunalwahl in Hessen. Und sag uns mal so, typischerweise reden wir auch nicht über Themen, die uns nur so interessieren, weil sie irgendwie facettenreich interessant oder was auch immer sind. Sondern es geht ja immer so ein bisschen um das echte Leben und heute insbesondere. Heute geht's einfach, obwohl ich ein Mindset und den großen Exkurs und den Flug ins Weltraum und ein bisschen Fantasia und so. Aber heute geht's uns Eingemachte.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, weil du ja auch aufzeigst, wie man sich doch enormen Einfluss erkaufen kann. Man braucht dann nur mal so einen unabhängigen Kandidaten.
Ganz unabhängigen Kandidaten, ja.
Und dann könnte dann ein Milliardär möglicherweise seine Position gut durchdrücken. Das werden wir uns ansehen. Ich bin gespannt. Du hast es mir nur angedeutet bislang. Ich will mich nochmal mit dem Verhältnis Mensch und Maschine beschäftigen, aber jetzt nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich einen weiteren KI-Podcast dir anbiete. Nein, wir hören erst einmal, was Alex Karp, also der Chef von Palantir, über den Menschen und die Menschen und manche Menschen denkt. Dann gehen wir dann zu über, dass wir den Produzenten von Big Brother uns anhören. Und der sagt ein paar Dinge zu Reality TV.
Deutsches Big Brother?
Deutsches Big Brother. Endemol, also so. Ja, Endemol. Wir werden uns dann einen Clip aus Matrix ansehen. Es könnte ein bisschen abgetroschen sein. Denkt man jetzt, ach, jetzt bringt man nochmal einen Clip von Matrix.
Markus Karp, der sich auch schon fragte, was bei der Neu-Show ist.
Das haben wir doch schon alles. Ja, aber wir haben doch eigentlich noch nicht so richtig geklärt, warum liegen eigentlich die Menschen da in diesen Wannen und werden ausgesaugt, da heißt es ja die Energie. Aber welche Energie ist das eigentlich? Das war doch vielleicht immer so eine Frage der Plausibilität. Ist das so sinnvoll, diese Konstruktion? Ich habe jetzt erkannt, doch, die ist sehr sinnvoll. Wir müssen das nur ein bisschen spezifizieren, was eigentlich der menschliche Anteil ist. Wie werden also die Maschinen gefüttert? Und das sehen wir, indem wir uns dann Laber-Podcasts vom Öffentlich-Rechtlichen finanziert ansehen, anhören. Wir werden auch zwei, drei Clips noch aus anderen Shows spielen, werden also sehen, wie da das Menschliche eingesaugt, abgesaugt wird. Es ist ziemlich gruselig, mitunter sehr vulgär. Ich habe auch einige Clips geschnitten gehabt, die ich dann doch wieder jetzt gestrichen habe, weil ich dachte, man kann es hier einfach nicht abspielen. Ich werde jedenfalls versuchen, den ganz großen Bogen dann zu schlagen. Am Ende kommen wir irgendwo bei der ARD raus.
Ja, okay. Sehr gut. Ich bin gespannt.
Bis morgen. Guten Abend. Wir begrüßen alle herzlich hier bei dieser besonderen Weihnachtsshow, die so kaum weihnachtlich wird.
Wieso? Kaum weihnachtlich? Also die Stimmungsmäßig.
Oder hast du was geplant oder möchtest du singen oder so?
Nein, wir haben ja hier unseren Weihnachtsbaum. Er brennt schon Lichterloh. Ja. Ein bisschen metaphorisch natürlich. Wir haben ein paar mehr, ich soll es nicht ansprechen, sagt Wolfgang, Weihnachtsstimmung und so. Aber fühlt ihr euch alle gesund? Es gab wieder mehr Krankmeldungen durch hier Ticketangebote.
Ich denke, du fragst jetzt ja die falschen, weil die die kranksten sind ja nicht gekommen.
Ist hier jemand krank zur Arbeit gekommen?
Nein, wir sind natürlich alle kerngesund und freuen sich.
Ich glaube, das Nein gilt, wir sind nicht bei der Arbeit.
Ja, eben. Aber wir schon. Wir müssen jetzt noch arbeiten.
Social Distancing und so.
Zwei Stunden.
Gut. Intro.
Ich bin übrigens von einem unserer Hörer gefragt worden, ob ich eigentlich so ein Weihnachtsmarkt-Typ sei.
Und?
Und die Reaktion des Publikums genau die richtige. Ich habe nämlich auch gelacht und habe da noch zurückgefragt. Schau doch mal tief in dein Herz. Sag mal Weihnachtsmarkt-Typ und denk dabei an mich. Glaubst du, das geht zusammen?
Ich hätte an dich gedacht.
Also ich mag keinen Glühwein. Ich will auch nicht irgendwas fettiges essen, was mir auf den Anzug tropft. Mir ist es auch eigentlich zu kalt draußen. Warum geht man auch nicht rein, wenn es Winter ist? Mir ist das Konzept Weihnachtsmarkt nicht schlüssig.
Ja, aber letztes Jahr hast du hier geglitzert wie ein Weihnachtsbaum, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Das stimmt, aber das kann man ja auch drinnen wunderbar tragen. Bist du ein Weihnachtsmarkt-Typ?
Ich muss einmal Weihnachtsmarkt. Allein mit dem Karussell. Und ich habe aber, mein Sohn hat gestern hier in der Hauptwache, für Leute, die es kennen, gesungen schon. Und da man den Eltern Bescheid gesagt hat, ich konnte leider nicht hin, hat man 300 Euro eingenommen. Also die Kinder haben eine gute Erfahrung gemacht, den Armen und Gebeutelten zu helfen. Von daher ist Weihnachten ganz gut konnotiert. Und eigentlich haben sie ihren Weihnachtsmarkt damit auch gestern absolviert. Glücklicherweise.
Wunderbar.
Darf ich fragen, wer das erste Mal heute bei uns ist? Wer ist zu Gast in Frankfurt für uns? Und jetzt nochmal Gegenprobe. Wer kommt aus Frankfurt? Ah ja, okay.
Es sind doch mehr Gäste hier. Und es sind gar nicht so viele Lokalpatrioten vielleicht hier. Deswegen musst du jetzt viel erklären.
Ja, genau. Also wir haben für alle, die heute neu hier sind oder den Podcast unserer Halbkenn, wir teilen uns ein paar Themen auf. Typischerweise geht es abwechslungsreich zu. Heute habe ich einen Blog, dann hat Wolfgang einen Blog. Wolfgang wird mit uns nachher, ich könnte es ja kurz anteasern, so ein bisschen Laber-Podcasts.
Das Verhältnis Mensch und Maschine. Aber nicht, dass wir jetzt über KI philosophieren, sondern wir beginnen bei Alex Karp, dem Gründer von Palantir und enden bei Laber-Podcasts, die das Öffentlich-Rechtliche produziert.
Ja.
Und es gibt einen Zusammenwagen.
Genau. Wir wollen euch also sagen, es besteht die Chance, dass ganz am Ende vielleicht noch mal so ein paar humoristische Sachen kommen. 21.45 Uhr vielleicht. Bis dahin ist heute auch ein bisschen Schulunterricht. Aber es sind Leute im Raum anwesend, die ich namentlich nicht nenne und nicht mal in der Funktion. Aber ich würde euch trotzdem aufrufen, falls ihr Sachen hört, bei denen ihr so denkt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein oder das finde ich gut, zeigt das ruhig. Auch wenn ihr nicht wisst, wer euch hier so zuhört. Aber zeigt es ruhig. Ihr seid Bürger dieses Landes. Ihr habt auch einen Bürgermeister. Wir reden gleich ganz viel über Bürgermeisterkommunalpolitik. Ihr habt auch einen Weihnachtsmarkt. Wir sehen gleich tolle Weihnachtsmärkte. Ihr wollt auch im Grunde in Wien leben, ohne dass ihr das wisst. Ich überzeug euch gleich davon. Ja, zeigt heute ein paar Emotionen, damit es was wird.
Wir lassen das natürlich so geheimnisvoll. Wir wollen nur sagen, es ist jetzt nicht der Bundespräsident im Raum, sondern ein bisschen Lokalpolitik, sagen wir so. An die wir auch besonders jetzt hier das mal adressieren, was wir gleich ausführen.
Der Bundespräsident würde uns hier gar nichts nützen heute. Und das wäre ja der Standardfall.
Genau. Das ist ja das Problem.
Wir sind ja nicht in der Paulskirche.
Wir haben ja ganz häufig diese Diskussionen, die vom Bundespräsidenten für den Bundespräsidenten geführt werden. Und genau das wollen wir nicht. Und wenn es eine Tradition in diesem Podcast gibt, dann war es doch, dass wir immer wieder mal beharrlich darauf hingewiesen haben, dass eigentlich in der Kommunalpolitik das Wichtige geschieht. Weshalb wir jetzt auch den Blick darauf werfen.
Genau. Und ihr seht schon, wir geben uns viel Mühe, um euch zu sagen, Kommunalpolitik ist echt wichtig. Und ich merke selber, wie schwer einem das fällt. Aber wir versuchen es jetzt, euch weise zu machen. Also hier in Frankfurt, ihr wisst es vielleicht, die wichtigste, schönste und bedeutendste Stadt Europas. Reaktionen 0. Wir haben einen Oberbürgermeister, der ist so alt wie ich. Das ist ziemlich cool. Denn ihr wisst, wer sonst so regiert in Deutschland. Das sind immer diese Glatzköpfe, die Kai, Wegner, Uwe, Becker oder irgendwie so heißen. Und es ist ja hier in Frankfurt anders. Unser Bürgermeister ist ja Mike Josef. Und nächstes Jahr ist Bergfest für ihn. Er ist dann drei Jahre im Amt und dann sind noch drei Jahre im Amt. Und wir haben im März, wir werden also das nächste Mal, wenn wir hier wieder im Salon sind, schon Bilanz ziehen können. Wir machen hier immer so kleine Bilanz, Pressekonferenzen zum Quartal und es steht also eine wichtige Wahl an. Und wir müssen das jetzt mal beschreiben, um was es hier eigentlich geht. Denn vielleicht sage ich so, Mike Josef droht leider die krasse Niederlage. Er wird dieses Amt verlieren und das wird sich drei Jahre anbarnen. Und danach werden alle sagen, hätte man sehen können, genau, gab es einen anderen Vorschlag. Nein, braucht man hier vielleicht einen Mindset-Shift oder so. Und ich sage ja. Und dann seht ihr schon, guckt ihr alle Wolfgang an. Wie Mindset? Hat Stefan jetzt Mindset gesagt? Ja.
Hast du also den Verstand verloren?
Habe ich. Habe ich den Verstand verloren? Genau. Also wir prügeln jetzt den Verstand in die Lokalpolitik wieder ein. Und dieses Szenario, wie Mike Josef hier verliert ist, dieses Jahr schon passiert, nämlich im September in Dortmund. Und wer jemanden, der Dortmund nicht kennt, erkläre ich hier kurz diese Grafik. Ihr seht bunte Balken. Ganz links ist die SPD. Und das sieht aus wie ein klarer Sieg. Aber ihr seht es auch, das sind noch nicht mal 30 Prozent. Also das ist für so eine erste Wahlrund. Und wir wissen ja dann immer so, Stichwahlen und so stehen dann an. Nicht allzu viel. Danach kommt die Grünen, die CDU, ein bisschen Linke. Dann kommt die AfD und dann kommt so ein bisschen ist alles egal, FDP und so. Und dann kommt jemand, da muss man selber so ein bisschen lesen, Kramer, Krämer, da für do heißt diese Partei. Was hat es mit der auf sich? Das versteht ja niemand. So ich will Folgendes zeigen.
Wie viel Prozent hat diese da für do? Hat die jetzt knapp 15 Prozent?
14,65.
Ja.
Also da hat man schon eine Stadt ordentlich aufgemischt. Dortmund ist ja nicht irgendwo, sondern die noch schlankende Herzkammer der Sozialdemokratie. Wenn man sich dieses mal als Lager veranschaut, dann haben wir hier ein linkes Lager, das ist völlig klar. Wir können die Grünen so ein bisschen reinrechnen, die Linken auf jeden Fall, die SPD auch. Und dem steht ein Lager gegenüber. Und da ist dann CDU, AfD und dieser Krämer drin. Das ist fast eins zu eins, so ein Wahlergebnis, wie es Mike Josef hatte. Man hat so ein Prozent Vorsprung, weil die über 70-Jährigen auch einen Kandidaten haben. Aber eigentlich hat die Stadt sich für Mike Josef entschieden. Und so sah es in Dortmund eigentlich auch aus. Also wenn man jetzt eine Stichwahl gemacht hätte, und wir wissen ja alle, AfDler, vor allem solche, die dann in ihr Profil schreiben, hallo, ich heiße Heiner, ich bin 65 Jahre alt, bin hier aufgewachsen, in die Welt gereist, aber der Dortmunder Heimat treu geblieben. Ja, total krass verankert, Ausbildung zum Zeitungsredakteur, Investor Relations Manager bei irgendeiner Wertpapierbank, Sprecher von EON und so weiter. Im Grunde weiß man, mit solchen Leuten macht man es nicht, was ja eigentlich bedeutet. Das sollte doch eine sichere Bank sein, um eine Stichwahl, die so ein Lager hervorruft, dass sagen, da gieße ich eh alle gegen den AfDler aussprechen und so weiter. Und das so ein bisschen schwächelt. Dann gibt es noch ein paar Sonstige, aus diesen 1% Vorsprungen müsste man doch irgendwie eine Beziehlinie kriegen. Aber nein.
Also die SPD war klar die stärkste Kraft und die CDU doch recht abgeschlagen. Aber dann gibt es die Stichwahl.
Genau. Und dann gibt es die Stichwahl. Und wir nähern uns jetzt langsam dieser Stichwahl. Den AfDler müssen wir also nicht vorstellen, mit dem will ja keiner was machen. Wie sieht es mit diesem Krämer aus? Martin Krämer. Wir sehen hier so ein, das ist kein Wahlplakat, vielleicht auch ein Wahlplakat. Aber man hatte so gute Ideen in dieser Agenturarbeit, dass man sich gesagt hat, wir machen auf der Webseite vier Bilder, die sich alle drei Sekunden immer durch so Schiebebewegungen, also das mute ich euch gar nicht zu. Wir zeigen uns die Bilder einzeln. Aber wir lesen mal vor für die Audiogäste in diesem Podcast. Alter Verwalter, endlich ein Gestalter, ihr unabhängiger Oberbürgermeisterkandidat für Dortmund. Bist du huckt?
Sprichst mich nicht so an.
Ja, 15 Prozent. Der hat ein parteiloses Mundwerk.
Der traut sich noch was. Man darf ja sonst nichts mehr sagen, aber der macht es noch.
Wieder der Spruch, ganz unabhängig, ganz richtig. Das ist die Konstante in dieser Webseite. Hier muss ich auch dreimal lesen. Ich lese euch mal vor. Einfach machen kann alles einfach machen.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen Lindemann. Einfach mal machen Podcast ist ja sein großes Projekt. Hast du gesehen, er geht jetzt damit auch auf Tournee.
Carsten Lindemann.
Schön, dass ihr euch vor uns entschieden habt. Also Carsten Lindemann ist auch mit seinem Podcast auf Tournee.
Ist sehr gut.
Hat auch Gäste.
Fährt er mit so einem Boot rum?
Nee, er ist an Land, hat auch Gäste und zwar Paul Ronzheimer war jetzt da in der Live-Show.
Wer hätte es gedacht, Mist, ich hätte zu Polymarkets gehen müssen.
Ja.
Ich hätte 100 Euro gewonnen. Apropos Carsten Lindemann, ich habe den Clip nicht, aber den Joke jetzt, wo du es aufgeworfen hast. Carsten Lindemann war gestern beim Deutschlandfunk-Interview der Woche. Danach hat Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag, die Tageszusammenfassung gemacht und eröffnet mit den Worten. Üblicherweise machen wir das nicht, aber wir zitieren jetzt mal unsere Journalistin, die Carsten Lindemann befragte. Und dann kam in Sekunde 38 des Podcasts, also die deutsche Tageszusammenfassung für ganz Deutschland, haben sie sich selber zitiert, wie sie sagen, Herr Lindemann, das stresst mich gerade ein bisschen, dass ich hier gar nichts aus Ihnen rauskriege. Das war der Gesprächs-Bit, den sie unbedingt, ja, also, das sind die Zustände. Okay, noch ein Bild von Martin Krämer. Nachdenken gut, vordenken besser. Ihr unabhängiger Oberbürgermeisterkandidat. So, wir haben es also hier mit absoluten Spitzenpersonal zu tun. Ich will Folgendes anmerken. Dieser Typ hat bei der Dortmunder Oberbürgermeisterwahl fast 0,3 oder so weniger Prozente bekommen als die ganze SPD bei der letzten Kommunalwahl in Hessen. Und wir wissen, der Wind hat sich gedreht, also März droht's.
Und wir müssen noch was zu der Farbe des Plakats sagen. Das ist einmal ein Gelb, das an die FDP gemahnt.
Will jemand den Erbe antreten hier meinsam?
Und man hat ein Blau, aber nicht ein AfD-Blau, sondern das Steuerberater-Blau, das auf Visitenkarten normalerweise ist.
Das seriöse Blau. Das Gotteslicht, als damals man nicht wusste, wo kriegt man das Gold her, um das zu malen. Also hat man blau gemalt. Also Martin Krämer stellt sich auf seine Webseite vor, Dortmund ist mein Herzensprojekt. Ich will, dass wir Dortmund zu einem Ort machen, auf dem wir alle stolz sein können. Mein Angebot an Sie, dafür do.
Also DO. Dortmund. Kennzeichnung.
Versteht ihr?
Toll.
Dafür doch. Ich will ein Oberbürgermeister sein für alle Dortmunderinnen und Dortmunder. Jeder ist bei mir gleich wichtig. Das ist ein sehr zentraler Satz in seiner Kampagne. Jeder gleich wichtig. Stellt sich die Frage, stimmt das denn? Wenn es stimmt, heißt das, wow, da muss man ganz schön arbeiten. Auf der Webseite gibt es einen Clip von ihm. Also man scrollt sich ein Stück weiter unter diese ganzen Plakate und diesen Spruch und dann kommt so ein Clip von ihm. Drei Stück. Ich habe uns mal ein mitgebracht. Er stellt sich vor, also stellt sich uns vor und auch seine Arbeitswut, die er jetzt für die Dortmunder aufbringt.
Ich wollte dich eigentlich fragen, wie es dir geht, aber wir machen das jetzt ganz lokal, pratiotisch.
Wie ist es?
Ja, läuft, würde ich sagen.
Muss?
Bist du schon im Wahlkampfmodus?
Wir haben noch sechs Monate.
Ich hätte gefragt, bist du betrunken?
Aber so sind auch die Laber-Podcasts gleich.
Ja, das ist hier Buma Laber-Podcast.
Er sieht aber auch überhaupt nicht nach Dortmund aus, sondern exakt so sehen ja alle aus, die in Düsseldorf nochmal an der Hotelbar schauen, was noch geht.
Das kann sein. Dortmund ist ja nicht allzu weit weg. Und am Ende will man auch in Düsseldorf mal großen Fußball sehen. Und dann fährt man natürlich auf die Erntribüne in Dortmund.
Du bist schon im Wahlkampfmodus.
Wir haben noch sechs Monate bis zur Kommunalwahl.
Also ich bin noch nicht im Wahlkampfmodus.
Der wird anders aussehen.
Das ist ganz, ganz klar. Und das ist auch gut, dass so ein Wahlkampf und so eine heiße Wahlkampfphase nicht über zig Monate geht. Nein, ich bin ja ein parteiloser Kandidat. Und als parteiloser Kandidat fehlen dir natürlich, ja, es fehlt hier so ein Parteibackground für viele organisatorische Dinge. Und das muss ich natürlich alles aufbauen. Das tue ich. Aber ich habe natürlich auch schon viele Themen, an denen ich arbeite. Logischerweise brauche ich natürlich auch einen Unterstützerkreis, wo ich schon sehr viel positives Feedback habe. Also ich sage mal, wir laufen an und ich muss natürlich eins machen. Und damit werden wir jetzt auch zügig beginnen, dadurch dass ich keine Partei als Marke habe, sondern sozusagen als Person für das Amt des Oberbürgermeisters von Dortmund kandidiere, habe ich natürlich nicht die Bekanntheit in die ganze Stadtgesellschaft hinein. Und die müssen wir natürlich bis zum Wahlkampf aufbauen, damit die Leute auch das Interesse an uns und unseren Themen haben.
Der arme Arme meint, wer kennt das nicht? Man hat ja gar keine Partei und muss das alles selber machen. Das ist voll die Arbeit, aber für die Dortmunder macht man es halt gerne. Denkt man sich Versprüche aus für die Webseite, tingelt so ein bisschen rum, um dann zurückgelehnt, Holz vertäffelt, da rum zu hängen und zu sagen, ja, ich hänge mich hier voll rein. Das ist im Grunde, wie man sich vorstellt, dass, also ich kenne mich wenig aus im Fußball, aber ich weiß, die Dortmunder müssen nicht gewinnen, aber sie müssen zeigen, dass sie Gras gefressen haben. Wenn du richtig geackert hast, dann kannst du auch auf Platz drei was werden. Also das ist hier. Wir haben in Frankfurt sehr gute Erfahrungen mit dritten Kandidaten, die unabhängig antreten. Wir hören jetzt mal beispielhaft Peter Wirth, unseren Bahnbarbo, für alle, die Frankfurt nicht kennen.
Du musst jetzt sagen, wer ist der Bahnbarbo?
Ja, ich sage es mal nicht, wer das ist, sondern ihr versucht jetzt Unterschiede zwischen Martin Krämer in Dortmund drittplatziert und Peter Wirth in Frankfurt drittplatziert zu sehen. Die FAZ stellt ihn uns vor.
Blendend weiße Zähne, dicke Oberarme und Sonnenbrille, das sind die Erkennungszeichen von Peter Wirth alias Bahnbarbo. Wenn er in der Straßenbahn sein körperliches Können zeigt, dann ist das Sport am Arbeitsplatz, denn er ist Straßenbahnfahrer bei der VGF, der Verkehrsgesellschaft Frankfurt.
Ich dehne jeden Tag und versuche meinen Körper flexibel zu halten.
Mein Motto ist, bist du flexibel wie der Baum im Wind.
Kein Lebenssturm dich hier bezwingt.
Und das stimmt.
Bürgermeister von Frankfurt-Bilder-Werden, erzählt er nach der Arbeit.
Punkte von mir werden in jedem Fall der Nachverkehr sein.
Da bin ich zu Hause.
Es wird die Wohnungssituation in dieser Stadt sein. Es wird die Jugend sein.
Wir brauchen mehr Betreuung dieser Jugend.
Warum hat das Jugendhaus am Wochenende zu? Ich muss auch arbeiten am Wochenende. Wir brauchen mehr Jugendbetreuer. Die müssen auch am Samstag und am Sonntag für diese jungen Leute da sein.
Wir müssen sie von der Straße holen.
Wir müssen Angebote machen.
Das passiert viel zu wenig.
Also hier Brücken bauen. Doch der Einzug ins Rathaus setzt einen erfolgreichen Wahlkampf voraus.
So, 10 Prozent. Applaus für den Bahnbarboa.
Faszinierend, ein Mann, der aussieht wie Arnold Schwarzenegger, aber Spagat kann wie die Käsler Zwillinge. Also das ist ja unglaublich.
Also Frankfurt ist eine coole Stadt. Ja, wir sehen es schon. Das sind unsere drittplatzierten. Aber leider reden wir über Dortmund und über die Zukunft von Frankfurt. Von daher, der Bahnbauer ist jetzt in Rente. Wir grüßen ihn, wenn wir ihn auf der Straße sehen. Okay, wenn ihr ihn seht. Zurück nach Dortmund. Thomas Westphal, diese Vorwahl oder dieser erste Wahlgang läuft durch. Er hat diese knapp 25 Prozent irgendwas und sieht, okay, das fällt, ist so ein bisschen, aber es hat sich auch so ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Thomas Westphal macht öffentlich folgende Kommentare.
Scharfe Worte auch in Richtung des ausgeschiedenen, parteilosen Martin Krämer.
Dass das Gespenst aus dem Süden mit dem Geldadel jetzt wieder nach Hause fährt.
Und darüber wollen wir noch mal sprechen. Martin Krämer.
So, wir haben gehört, ja. Das Gespenst des Geldadels. So hat er ihn betitelt.
Martin Krämer ist jetzt hier im Studio. Danke, dass Sie da sind. Sie waren gestern Abend nicht dabei. Sie haben es aber wahrscheinlich schon gesagt bekommen, was davon Thomas Westphal in ihre Richtung gegangen ist. Ihre Reaktion heute nach einer Nacht durchatmen?
Ja, das ist ehrlich gesagt eine unglaublich armselige Form der Diffamierung und Verleumdung meiner Person, meines Wahlkampfs, aber auch der Menschen, die mich dabei unterstützt haben und auch meiner Familie. Und ich muss sagen, ich finde das einfach nur noch unwürdig und gerade für einen Oberbürgermeister und eine Person, die dieses Amt in Zukunft in der Stadt innehaben möchte.
Haben Sie ihn heute darauf angesprochen? Hatten Sie Kontakt?
Nein.
Ja, heul doch. Das sind ganz schlimme Leute, die wir hier sehen.
Selbst die Familie hat jetzt darunter gelitten. Alle haben darunter gelitten.
Habt ihr gehört, das ist eine Deformierung des Arbeitgebers standfand? Nö, den können wir immer nachgehen. Also Herr Krämer fühlt sich ganz schlimm diffamiert und er hat auch schlechte Laune und ich will noch mal aufzeigen, ja, bisher Bahnbabow ist Maßstab für was geht. Martin Krämer ist, was man bekommt. Und man weiß noch nicht mal darüber Bescheid, sondern Thomas in Westphalen macht so ganz zaghaft, nachdem der Wahlkampf gelaufen ist, das hätte man ja auch mal früher machen können. So eine Andeutung, Gespenst, Geldadel und so weiter und so fort. Zum Glück gibt es Lokaljournalismus. Wer ihn bei den großen Zeitungen sucht, ha ha, denkste. Man muss natürlich zum Nordstadtblogger gehen. Dort wird gefragt, was sagt denn nicht diese unabhängige OB-Kandidatur von Martin Krämer über den Kommunalwahlkampf in Dortmund? Und die Antwort ist, also die CDU erinnert das alles, was hier so stattfindet, an Elon Musk, was genau? Ah, da hat irgend so ein Typ einen offenen Brief geschrieben. Jochen Opländer. Schon mal gehört? Kennt jemand Jochen Opländer? Okay, drei Hände gehen hoch. Man fragt sich immer, wer sind die Milliardäre in Deutschland? Ja, es gibt so 150 Leute, wer sind die nochmal? Fliegen die alle nur mit dem Boot und ihren Trinktüten, Milliarden rum und so? Nö, manche sitzen auch in Dortmund und machen Lokalpolitik. Aber nicht selber, weil die sind 90 Jahre alt. Die machen das dann über Bande. Und in dem Falle ist das hier Jochen Opländer. Der ist auf folgende Weise mit dem Martin Krämer verbandelt. Jochen Opländer, das O steht für Opländer, in Vilo, die Vilo SE, das ist also eine große Firma in Dortmund. Und der Martin Krämer ist dort Aufsichtsratmitglied. Und der Jochen Opländer ist natürlich in seinem eigenen Laden Ehrenvorsitzender des Aufsichtsrats. Also die kennen sie ich halt. Und Thomas Westphal sagt völlig zurecht, ja, da hat sich irgendwie so einen milliardären Kandidaten gekauft oder produziert oder wie auch immer man das heutzutage nennt. Nur das hätte man ja auch mal im Wahlkampf zum Thema und so weiter, statt einfach abzuwarten, bis der Wahlkampf läuft und man feststellt, oh Mist, ich habe 25 und der hat 15 Prozent. Also das sind natürlich die Pferde schon davon, Gollöp.
Ja, kann ich mir mal wieder genau vorstellen, weil man sich mit dieser besagten Firma es nicht verscherzen wollte, Gewerbesteuer und so weiter. Hat man dann gerade auch, weil es noch zwei aus der SPD da gibt, die da auch gerne schon mal mit dem Golf spielen, gesagt, nee, lass das mal lieber nicht anspruchen.
Wir können ja mal alle raten, ist Herr Opländer nicht nur Ehrenvorsitzender seines Aufsichtsrats, sondern auch Ehrenbürger der Stadt Dortmund. Natürlich. Wer hat ihn zum Ehrenbürger gemacht? Thomas Westphalen in seiner Amtszeit. Also diese... Ja klar, da will man sich die Hände nicht verbrennen, aber vielleicht sollte man irgendwann auch mal zulangen. Jedenfalls gab es da einiges drunter und drüber. Die CDU hat zum Beispiel mit einem offenen Brief gegen diese Aktionen von Opländer angeschrieben. Und da muss man immer denken, wenn die Parteien offene Briefe schreiben, so wie jeder normale Mensch, wenn man sich fragt, an wen und so überhaupt. Und die CDU. Also wenn selbst der CDU ein bisschen zu bunt wird. So, worauf genau reagiert die offene Brief an Herrn Opländer? Reaktion auf Walauffruf. Ah, es gab einen Walauffruf. Ja, in den Ruhrnachrichten erschien ein Text, da hat einfach der Milliardär, kann man es lesen, geschrieben, mein persönlicher Brief an Sie zur Kommunalwahl. So im Sinne von, die Zeitung ist mein Briefausträger, also ich schicke jetzt eben mal so ein Brief nach Hause. Und wenn man dann da ins Detail geht, sieht man auch, ah ja, es geht um einen vernachlässigtes Stadtbild und einen der gefährlichsten Hauptbahnhöfe Deutschlands. Und da, falls jemand gar nicht weiß, wo er hier ist, ist eine ganz große Brücke zu Frankfurt am Main, also Bahnhofsviertel, da gehen gleich alle Lampen an. So, der Wahlkampf, wir können ihn hier nur kurz zusammenfassen, wurde so weit getrieben, dass in meiner Tagesthemsendung für ganz Deutschland das hier gesendet wurde.
Wenn es dunkel wird am Dortmunder Hauptbahnhof. Und mit der Dunkelheit kommt auch die Unsicherheit. Denn fast alle, die ich gefragt habe, haben kein gutes Gefühl mehr, wenn sie abends dort unterwegs sind. Auch Pendlerin Valeria Meisterjahn.
Also ich habe immer meinen Pfefferspray abends dabei, wenn ich mit der Bahn unterwegs bin. Ich fahre regelmäßig auch früh und spät, wenn es dunkel ist. Und an deutschen Bahnhöfen fühle ich mich ehrlicherweise nicht mehr sicher.
Man hat jede Minute Angst, dass irgendjemand kommt und das beklaut oder so.
Das ist jetzt hier ganz normal geworden.
Vor allem am Nordausgang fühlen sich die meisten unwohl. Wo es düster ist, wo wenig los ist, hier wartet niemand gerne lange auf die Weiterfahrt.
Wenn ich so um 20 Uhr aus Aachen ankomme, rufe ich eigentlich immer auch meinen Papa an und frag, kannst du mich hier einsammeln? Und der steht doch immer hier vorne, steigt aus und sammelt mich dann ein. Man hat immer Angst, dass etwas passiert. Ja, aber nicht nur in Bahnhöfen, auch generell überall.
Fast jeder Zweite fühlt sich in Deutschland im öffentlichen Raum unsicher, so ein aktueller ARD-Deutschland-Trend.
Nichts von dem, was wir hier gesehen haben, ist ja so ausgedacht wie Föllevans Ideen, dass ein Herr Opländer sich einfach jemanden erfinden kann, der für ihn lokale Politik aufrollt, so von hinten. Sondern das sind ja ernstzunehmende Probleme. Also der Dortmunder Hauptbahnhof, ich kenne ihn so ein bisschen aus meiner Studienzeit in NRW, der Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof längst nicht so gefährlich, wie man hört immer. Weil man hört ja viel von Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, von Leuten, die gar nichts mit Frankfurt zu tun haben. Das reicht nicht mit dem Hauptbahnhof. Aber diese Probleme sind ja wirklich da. Und jetzt ist auch ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht man damit um? Weil die Antwort kann nicht sein, dass wir sagen, stimmt, es ist schon wirklich ein bisschen unangenehm am Dortmunder Hauptbahnhof. Und zum Glück ist dieser Mann da. Herr Opländer mit seinen 90 Jahren, der wie Batman da irgendwie abends aufräumt. Oder was? Also was ist das Szenario?
Der wird ja auch nicht so häufiger am Hauptbahnhof sein, nämlich.
Ich glaube nie. Das wäre meine Vermutung. Nie. Jetzt haben wir aber folgendes Problem. Der Herr Opländer hatten Kandidaten, der nicht bei der Stichwahl ist, aber als Platz drei natürlich ein Zügelein an der Waage. Also was geschieht? Ein Wahlaufruf gegen die SPD. Also was geschieht? Wahlaufruf funktioniert. Zack, Thomas Westphal verliert. Nach 85 Jahren geht Dortmund von der SPD verloren an die CDU. Und ich habe vorhin, also es gab eine kleine, aber linke Mehrheit an Dortmund.
Das heißt, die CDU hatte ja dann sich auch befriedet mit dem Herrn Krämer. Das ist ja interessant, weil sie ja erst noch gegen Opländer und Krämer wohl angeschrieben haben.
Also in dieser CDU stecken jetzt 15 Prozent erster Wahlgang Krämer, Opländer. Was bedeutet? Nicht nur konnte Thomas Westphal dort seinen Posten nicht verteidigen und nach 85 Jahren ging das an die CDU, sondern es ging an eine CDU, der man immer sagen kann, hallo, ich bin Herr Opländer, ihr seid es nur wegen mir. Das ist das größte Drama überhaupt, was da passieren kann. Ja, und es ist genau so passiert. Und jetzt ist die Frage, welche Stadt hat nochmal irgendwelche Milliardäre? Ach ja, Frankfurt. Wer hat noch mal ein Hochsicherheitsproblem irgendwie? Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof und muss das auch niemanden erklären, wenn er sagt, ich mache hier einen Law and Order Wahlkampf. Also ich bin gespannt. Wir können wirklich ein Polymarkets Ding einreichen. Welcher Milliardär von Frankfurt wird welchen Kandidaten aufstellen um? Und das ist eine gesetzte Sache. Da muss man nicht wetten, das Bahnhofsviertel zum mega Thema der nächsten drei Jahre zu machen.
Ich denke gerade an meine Stadt Koblenz, die ja auch einen Bahnhof hat.
Ein Hauptbahnhof oder Bahnhof?
Ein Hauptbahnhof und die auch ein Milliardär hat und sie kennen ihn alle. Es ist nämlich der Milliardär Gotthard, der Nios mit Julian Reichelt finanziert. Und wenn der jetzt zum Beispiel Salon-Abonnent ist, dann kommt er auch gleich auf Ideen.
Ja und ich will es dir mal zeigen.
Oder ich frage ihn einfach mal, ich könnte ihn ja anschreiben, ob ich vielleicht der der dritte unabhängige Kandidat bin und trägste dann alle aus.
Alle Ideen sind jetzt willkommen, was auf jeden Fall da ist.
Die haben ja noch andere berühmte Söhne der Stadt, zum Beispiel Thomas Anders. Vielleicht kann man da fragen.
Aber der macht nicht Lawn Order, der macht wie park ich mein Auto und wo.
Genau, der fährt hier Bentley.
Und er parkt den immer schief und überall, wo er will. Und alle wissen, er ist gerade da. Ich bin beseelt. Ich präge mich doch hier nicht auf.
Ja, das ist ja die alte Logik. Parkverbote gibt es ja in dem Sinne nicht. Das sind ja einfach nur teure Parktickets. So muss man es sehen.
So, wir haben also hier ein Problem, das ist zu lösen. Eine Lösung wäre, kriegen die Leute denn gar nichts mehr mit? Muss man denen alles erzählen? Wo ist denn hier die emotionale Verbindung zum Ort? Wenn man die fragt zum Thema, ja der Opländer hat jetzt irgendwie die SPD geklaut und damit ja, wir sind jetzt CDU-Opfer. Was sagen die Leute dann? In Dortmund, und es ist auch wieder eine große Parallele zu Frankfurt, haben die Leute den Kopf immer schon voll. Wir hören jetzt einen Clip aus dem Tagesteam, also bundesweite Berichterstattung. Es geht nicht um den Oberbürgermeisterwahlkampf, vielleicht findet jemand raus, worum es geht.
Also für uns Dortmunder ist das natürlich enttäuschend, das muss man schon sagen. Das sind ja nicht gerade, wir haben ja nicht gerade eine Fan-Friendschaft mit dem Dosen-Sport-Verein.
Ja, für mich hat es einen faden Ballgeschmack, man ist ein bisschen enttäuscht, aber Geld regiert die Welt.
Haben sie in ihrem ganzen Konsortium wenigstens jetzt mal einen vernünftigen rumhängen. Mehr kann ich dazu gerade nicht sagen, tut mir leid.
So, sehr erregte, traurige, trübsinnige, melancholische Dortmunder. Worum geht es hier? Jürgen Klopp geht zu Red Bull.
Also man hat in Dortmund gefragt, wie findet ihr, dass Jürgen Klopp zu Red Bull geht?
Die Leute müssen also die Frage beantworten können, wie findest du es, dass der Opländer der SPD den Wahlsieg hier weggekauft hat und jetzt so ein CDU-Vorziel zu seinen Gnaden regiert? Ja. Und dann müssen die Reaktionen eigentlich dieselben sein. So, hier ist also ein Problem zu lösen und das lösen wir jetzt. Und wie? Indem wir zum einen sagen, wir wollen mal nicht länger unzufrieden sein mit der SPD, weil wir jetzt langsam wissen, alles, was danach kommt, ist auf jeden Fall beschissener. Aber die SPD muss es halt anders machen. Und die Frage ist, wie anders? Und ich sage, die SPD braucht jetzt einen Sinn dafür, ein Gespür für virtuelle Politik. Ja, es gibt echte Probleme und auch echte Lösungen. Und dann sitzt man in ewig langen Verwaltungen da und fasst dann alles in so einer Sonntagsrede, möglichst zu Weihnachten, damit jemand zuhört, zusammen. Aber das ist es irgendwie nicht. Sondern wir brauchen es irgendwie anders. Und wir sehen das ja schon in den Oppositionsarbeiten. Also hier in Hessen ist ja auch die Fläche wird so ein bisschen von CDU und AfD aufgewühlt und in den Städten das Milieu schiftet so wie in Kassel zu den Grünen oder was auch immer. Und wir gucken jetzt uns mal bundesweit an, wie die Stimmung so ist. Man könnte zum Beispiel als Oppositionsarbeit, bevor sie droht, schon mal sagen, wir machen so ein paar Aktionen. Wir machen es mal symbolisch, wie hier zum Beispiel in Karlsruhe.
Wir haben heute die Stadt beerdigt.
So die Stadt beerdigen.
Um das Geld zum Leben zu haben, soll fortan 50 Euro kosten.
Acht Kultureinrichtungen stehen vor dem Aus. Dazu gehören die Alte Hackerei, das Kohi und das Sandkontheater. Seit Jahren sind die Kommunen strukturell unterfinanziert. Das sehen wir nicht nur in Karlsruhe, das sehen wir in Mannheim, in Pforzheim, in Heidelberg, in ganz Baden-Württemberg. Und wir sagen ganz klar nicht mit uns. Und deswegen treffen wir uns um 12 Uhr, am 8. November in Stuttgart, denn die Kommunen sind am Limit.
Ja, die Kommunen sind am Limit, also beerdigen wir jetzt erstmal die Stadt. Es könnte sein, dass wir dann, wie Phoenix aus der Asche, irgendeine Idee haben oder so. Aber erstmal wird hier beerdigt. Also der Zustand, wie er jetzt ist, also so geht es nicht weiter.
Ja, und man trifft sich aber in Stuttgart, also in der Landeshauptstadt, und schließt sich zusammen offenbar mit anderen Städten, die ja hier angesprochen wurden. Ja, das scheint ja nicht unerheblich zu sein. Denn eigentlich ist man ja doch mit einer erheblichen Macht ausgestattet, wenn man sie bündeln kann.
Ja, das war meine Idee, die ich Thomas Westphal ja im 1 zu 1 Gespräch damals in Dortmund vorgetragen habe. In Dortmund, im Ruhrgebiet, wurde die Familie erfunden, weil dort die Kohle war, um überhaupt Fabriken zu machen. Und weil Fabriken braucht man Familien. Irgendwer muss ja, wie Bundespräsident nochmal sagte, danke, liebe Hausfrauen, dass sie die Kleidung sauber gemacht haben bis zu den 70er Jahren. Sonst hätten die ja alle schwarz, wie sie rauskommen, wieder rein in die Grube gemusst. Und in Dortmund, in diesen Regionen wurde ja bahnbrechendes, da wurde ja wirklich zivilisatorischer Fortschritt wurde dort organisiert. Und jetzt plötzlich, und das will ich mal kontrastieren, was wir eben gehört haben, also man könnte einfach hingehen und die große Ansage machen, wir beerdigen jetzt die Stadt, wir zimonieren Sarg, wir treffen uns alle in Stuttgart, wir sagen, so geht es nicht weiter und zwar unabhängig davon, wer regiert. Jetzt hören wir in dieser gleichen baden-württembergischen Gemengelage, wie die SPD damit umgeht.
Für den SPD-Kreisverband ein Unding. Er hat deshalb eine Petition gestartet gegen den Kahlschlag an unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen, wie es dort heißt, durch die CDU-geführte Stadtverwaltung.
Ich erwarte von jedem Oberbürgermeister und von jeder Oberbürgermeisterin, dass sie schon vor Beginn von solchen schwierigen Haushaltsberatungen klar ihrer Verwaltung zum Ausdruck geben, dass ein Kinder- und Jugendlichen nicht geschworen wird.
Seid ihr noch wach? Also sie erwartet es wirklich, dass man jetzt mal die Kinder schützt...
.berat werden darf. Das fällt uns langfristig auf die Füße.
Die Stadt Stuttgart möchte sich nicht zum Stand der Haushaltsberatungen äußern, teilt jedoch mit. Die bisherigen Beratungen lassen darauf schließen, dass es trotz der sehr angespannten Haushaltslage möglich sein wird, auch künftig gute, umfassende Angebote in den Bereichen Jugendhilfe und Bildung zu machen.
Ja, gut gebrüllt, Löwer. Also ich fordere das auch für die Kinder. Das ist ja wirklich ganz schlimm und so. Und das sollte man jetzt mal machen. Typischerweise wundern wir uns immer, dass Politiker, die wirklich was wollen, dann irgendwie auf der Straße stehen und sagen, hinter mir das Weise Haus, vor mir das Kanzleramt, ich möchte hier was, ich hatte hier einen Termin. In dem Sinne würde ich der SPD sagen, bitte geht einfach auf die Straße her. Also wenn ihr nur ein Pressestatement macht, selbst das bitte einfach auf der Straße. Zeigt, dass ihr hier seid, am Computer sich mal kurz wegdrehen. Ja, weil ich mache schnell diese Excel-Zeile und dann, ja ich fordere jetzt wirklich, dass die 17.000 Excel-Zeile mal ein bisschen grün wird.
So könnte uns das auf die Füße fallen.
Das könnte uns langfristig ganz doll auf die Füße fallen. Das ist gut, dass sie gewarnt hat. So was meine ich jetzt mit virtueller Politik? Ich will eine kleingeistige Antwort geben und danach, verspreche ich, kommt eine ganz große, dann kommt der Mindset-Shift. Wir gehen aber erst mal nach Ostdeutschland, Quedlinburg. Christian Sievers hat sich gesagt, der Osten ist unterbelichtet. Was sich gleich herausstellen wird, ist nicht ganz so. Denn er ist auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren. Es ist der schönste Weihnachtsmarkt von ganz Deutschland.
Hallo Anne, guten Abend Ihnen allen. Der erste Dezember in diesem mittelalterlichen Städtchen. Im Grunde ist die gesamte Stadt ein einziger Weihnachtsmarkt. Gefühlt verkauft hier jeder Glühwein, der ein Fenster zur Straße hat. Und es ist auch tatsächlich malerisch. Aber und damit sind wir bei dem Thema, dass wir alle, die Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes, zunehmend zu spüren bekommen. Den Städten geht die Puste aus. Sie sind pleite oder sie stehen kurz davor.
Quedlinburg hat gar nichts.
Hast du gesehen, diese Frau hinten im Hintergrund mit dem roten Schal? Die freut sich irrsinnig, im Fernsehen zu sein.
Ja, Quedlinburg ist so dankbar, dass es Fernsehen da ist. Sie haben den Weihnachtsmarkt leer geräumt, ein paar Zaungäste da hingestellt und gesagt, hier ist so friedlich, hier ist so schön. Also mehr virtuelle Politik geht gar nicht.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip jetzt so eine Realität, die man geschaffen hat, mit der man auch wunderbar den Bundespräsidenten empfangen kann.
Genau.
Dann sagt er, endlich wieder unter normalen Leuten.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mal, in welchem Bundesland das ist. Ich gucke ja diese Nachrichten auch noch mit einem Auge.
Du kannst dir sicher sein, es wird Menschen aus Quedlinburg geben, die uns zuhören und wir grüßen sie an dieser Stelle herzlich.
Ja, Grüße an euch. Und jetzt überlegen wir mal.
Mach das doch nicht so ohne Phase.
Die Frage ist ja immer, darf man noch grüßen oder gilt noch die Losung, mit Nazis redet man nicht? Denn, aber die hören doch nicht hier zu. Ja, ja, also wir hoffen natürlich. Aber ich möchte darauf hinweisen, wir gucken jetzt einen Clip, uns wird Quedlinburg vorgestellt.
Also Stefan, noch ein paar Podcasts und du darfst wirklich einfach nicht mehr in den Osten reisen.
Ja, mache ich als Ossi sowieso nur noch Militant. Von daher ist das kein Unterschied. Also uns wird jetzt Quedlinburg vorgestellt. Nicht gesagt wird uns, wer dort den Wahlkreis gewonnen hat. Diese Zahlen werde ich uns dann nennen. Aber wir können ja schon mal überlegen, sind es 20, 30 oder 40 Prozent für die AfD?
Quedlinburg, Welterbe der Menschheit, 1100-jähriges Fachwerkensemble am Fuße des Harzes und international beliebter Besuchermagnet Sachsen-Anhalt. Die ostdeutsche Kleinstadt ist abhängig vom Welterbetourismus, ohne ging es kaum.
Das wäre eine wirtschaftliche Tragödie hier. Also wir sind wirklich ein Touristen-Hotspot. Wir sind keine Schwerindustrie oder sowas und wir leben tatsächlich vom Großteil des Tourismus hier.
Also es braucht ja ein bisschen Geld, um dann auch die Stadt zu erhalten und die ganzen Fachverkäuser zu sanieren.
Also wenn wir die Touristen nicht hätten, ich sag's einfach mal, von den Einheimischen, von den Quedlinburger könnten wir nicht leben.
Aha, sagte sie und Wahlkreis 68, Christina Baum, AfD, 39 Prozent. Also wenn in diesen Orten jeder zweite AfD wählt und dann kommt eine Fernsehkamera und man ruft nicht Lügenpresse, sondern ja, stimmt, wir könnten hier ohne die Leute gar nicht leben. Mit wem führt man dann Gespräche? Also mit den Fernsehleuten, vielleicht sollte man mal so ein Selbstgespräch führen. Jedenfalls, sie wollten virtuelle Politik, sie haben sie bekommen.
Erst mit der Deutschen Einheit vor 35 Jahren begann der Wiederaufbau bis zur Neuen Blüte.
Blühende Landschaften, ja, also wenn eins blühende Landschaften ist, dann Quedlinburg. Ich habe über die Jahre versucht, es differenziert zu sagen, aber da ich selber ein Aussie bin, sage ich, das ist einfach bescheuert, was wir hier sehen. Das ist Kommunalpolitik, die einfach komplett gekippt ist, ja. Das ist einfach schon verloren. Hier wählen schon 40 Prozent der Leute der AfD und da gibt es außer den schönen Schein eigentlich nichts. Und dann ist man halt Adventsstadt und hofft einfach, obwohl es schöner Frühling, Sommer, Herbst ist, dass möglichst schnell Winter wird, damit man wieder seinen Adventsstadtdasein machen kann. Das ist alles nicht gut. Aber das kostet halt ein bisschen.
Der schöne Schein heute trügt, denn Sanierung und Erhalt des Weltkulturerbes ist für die Kommune eine enorme Belastung. Für Quedlinburg ist natürlich immer das Welterbe eine finanzielle Herausforderung, die wir sehr gerne annehmen. Aber wir brauchen im Jahr ungefähr 6 Millionen Euro an Eigenmitteln nur für das Welterbe. In der mittelfristigen Finanzplanung entsteht so laut Bürgermeister ein jährliches Defizit von circa 5 Millionen Euro.
5 Millionen Euro, weil das irgendwie 6 Millionen kostet und so weiter, da die Fassaden schön anzumalen. Er hat natürlich Ideen, wie man das jetzt mal vielleicht mit ein bisschen so, vielleicht könnte man mal was nicht ganz so virtuelles machen.
Also wir entwickeln ein Gebiet erneuerbaren Energien, was ein Industriegebiet speisen soll, am Rande von Quedlinburg. Und wenn wir das realisiert bekommen, gegen auch Widerstände, dann bringt uns das jährlich 10 Millionen, dann werden wir Außenschneider. Aha.
So erneuerbare Energien in Quedlinburg. Ich nehme mal an, er redet von Windrädern im Wald und sagt schon dazu, wenn wir das so gegen Widerstände hinkriegen.
Und die Widerstände liegen bei 39 Prozent exakt.
Genau. Also wir sind hier sozusagen auch verloren im Gebiet. Ja, so. Aber das hat ja natürlich alles eine große Misere. Allerdings diesen kleinen Exkurs sozusagen. Wir sind schon jetzt in einer gekippten Region, die kommunalpolitisch noch so einiges versucht. Also noch ist es die CDU, die dort den Bürgermeister stellt, dort den Landrat. Und sie haben schon allein nicht das Programm. Wir sind Adventsstadt. Wir machen Weihnachtsmarkt. Weihnachtsmarkt ist im Grunde dieses Wir schneiden uns alle nur noch die Haare. Wir verkaufen das alle nur noch Glühwein. Und jetzt legen sie aber bei ihnen, dass nicht reicht, auf diese virtuelle Realität, noch mal einen virtuellen Realitätsschleier oben drüber. In der Hoffnung, dass es niemand merkt.
Aber wie im ganzen Land haben sie auch hier zwischen Baumkuchenbäckereien und Fachwerkidyll jetzt gerade mit einer zusätzlichen Herausforderung zu kämpfen, nämlich mit der Sicherheit. Wenn es dunkel wird in Quedlinburg, beginnt für Tausende Besucher Adventsstimmung. Für die Verantwortlichen beginnt die sogenannte abstrakte Lage. Das heißt auf alles vorbereitet sein, Sicherheit gewährleisten. Das Konzept ist seit einem Jahr in Arbeit. Polizei, Rettungsdienst, eine private Security-Firma mit mobilen Patrouillen sind die Basis. Wie viele Schritte machen Sie so einen Tag? Ich sag mal, sieben Kilometer sind das mindestens.
Sieben Kilometer ist ein normaler Spaziergang, darauf ist man nicht stolz. Das ist so virtuell. Ich will es jetzt erklären. Die CDU regiert Landstriche, in denen es nichts mehr zu regieren gibt. Man darf sich aber mit der AfD nicht verscherzen. Also hofft man mal, dass man noch so einen Windpark, aber ne, wird schon nichts. Also macht man einen Weihnachtsmarkt und damit beim Weihnachtsmarkt nicht auffällt, dass das eigentlich nichts ist, sagt man, oh, das ist ganz wichtig, wir müssen hier für die Sicherheit sorgen und so. Als ob irgendwer in Quedlinburg irgendwen bedroht. Als ob das da irgendwie notwendig ist, in Quedlinburg nochmal den Weihnachtsmarkt zu schützen. Aber sie gehen das komplett durch.
Sichtbare und unsichtbare Zufahrtssperren, verkleidete Betonpoller. Massiv. Über Details wollen sie lieber nicht reden. Überhaupt sollen sich alle sicher fühlen, ohne ständig erinnert zu werden, was dafür nötig ist. Also keine Alarmstimmung erzeugen sozusagen?
Nein, gar nicht. Gar nicht.
Deswegen immer freundlich durchgehen, lächeln.
Und dann ist es auch alles ein bisschen geschmeidiger, sag ich es mal.
Ja, wie auch sonst. Also mit dem Gewehr auf, Leute schon mal prophylaktisch zielen, man weiß es ja nicht. Ich finde es übrigens toll, wie Christian Sievers hier so eine richtige Ortsbegehung macht. So, als wollte er der nächste Bürgermeister von Quedlinburg werden.
Ja, da reicht ja ein bisschen. Der kommt aus dem Fernsehen zu sein und schon wirst du da...
Ja, er macht aber wirklich die Gesten. Man hat sie ja selbst hunderttausendmal anmoderiert. Und jetzt kann er sie eins zu eins umsetzen dort nochmal kräftig auf den Block klopfen. Ob dann auch alles sicher und stabil ist.
Ja, also hier sieht jetzt einfach die SPD, finde ich, was kommunalpolitisch möglich ist. Aus nichts wird eine Adventsstadt gezaubert und Sicherheit esoterik, die die Waage halten soll. Das ist vom Konzept her wie, du machst ein 9-Euro-Ticket und sagst, das machen wir aus einem Grund, das ist eine inflationssenkende Maßnahme. Und dann machst du ein Jahr später das um 500 Prozent teurer. Das ist diese Art von Politik. Das ist, also wenn wir erstmal, dann ist hier, dann machen wir richtig, dann sorgen wir für Ordnung. Wir sparen 30 Milliarden Euro und im Gesetz steht dann, dreht so 68 Millionen im ersten Jahr und danach kostet es. Also Bürgergelddiskussion um Faktor 350 verrechnet. So, das ist diese Art und ich frage mich so, warum sitzt man bei der SPD nicht zusammen und sagt sich, komm, die erfinden Weihnachtsmärkte, selbst die Tagesthemen fahren dahin und dann holen die noch so einen Typ, der allen vorgaukelt, hier wird gehandelt, wir schießen auch für sie und so. Da gibt es auch Gegenprogramme, da gibt es auch funktionale Äquivalente, wo man sagen kann, liebe SPD, mach doch mal deinen Gegenentwurf.
Zumal man ja, wenn es dort ein Kriminalitätsproblem geben sollte, sich fragen könnte, wie löst man das eigentlich? Weil das ist ja einfach nur zu sagen, wir schotten mal den Weihnachtsmarkt vor allem schlimm ab.
Na ja, man kann jetzt nicht mit dem Auto drauf fahren, aber wenn die Nachricht lautet, Glühwein vergiftet, was machen die dann in Quedlinburg? Dann war das alles für die Katz. Wenn man das so treibt wie die CDU, dann weiß man, da gibt es kein Ende. Kleiner Exkurs, das Wählerpublikum für diese Art Politik.
In acht Metern Tiefe hat sich Christian Klaus einen Atomschutzbunker in sein Haus gebaut.
Ran, der heute schon Alberichterstattung.
Wenn ich in die Ukraine schaue, dort wird Flächen decken, alles vernichtet. Ganze Städte, ganze Häuser, also alles, was auch zivil ist. Kindergärten, Schulen, alles.
Spezialtüren, Belüftungsanlagen, Vorratsschränke. Vorbereitet sein für einen Ernstfall, der hoffentlich nie kommen wird.
Also ich selbst werde von dem Bunker wahrscheinlich nichts haben.
Das ist einfach eine Sache für die Familie.
Überlegt mal kurz, warum wird er davon nichts haben? Warum ist das nur für seine Familie die Auflösung?
Wenn es zum Ernstfall kommt, werde ich einberufen.
Ich denke, man baut sich so einen Bunker, um nicht einberufen zu werden.
Ja, ja, eben. Da würde man sich ja dann verstecken.
Aber bei ihm klopfen sie an der Tür und sagen, es droht Gefahr. Und er sagt, ich habe einen Bunker, aber ich komme jetzt mit ihnen mit und gehe in die Trex-Kasernen, die die Bundeswehr nun wirklich legendär machen.
Und lasst mich an der Front erschießen, wenn die Familie unten im Bunker hockt. Aber wir könnten uns, wir könnten uns doch wirklich vorstellen, dass in diesem Beitrag noch, sagen wir, Florian Schnaub eingeblendet wird, die sagt, ja, ich denke, wir müssen als Gesellschaft resilienter werden und das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Ja, und dann Claudia Mayor mit so einer weilerlichen Stimme. Leider hat er nicht tief genug gebuttelt, aber die Idee war voll gut. Die Russen haben jetzt größere Atomwaffen und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich alles ganz, jetzt hört mal auf den Bürgermeister aus Quedlinburg von der CDU. Es ist sehr verrätterisch, finde ich die Worte.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Probleme, Herausforderungen, Finanzsorgen geredet. Was würden Sie sagen, wie optimistisch sind Sie, dass dieses Land das tatsächlich in den Griff bekommt? Weil überall die Kommunen ja sagen, so geht es nicht weiter.
Das ist richtig. Ich denke, eine Beruhigung wird sich wieder einstellen, wenn die Leute merken, man kann sicher auf die Weihnachtsmärkte gehen. Wir sollten einen gewissen Standard an Sicherheit gewährleisten, aber wir sollten es dabei jetzt auch belassen und nicht weiter übertreiben.
Wir sollten es mal nicht weiter übertreiben, sagt der CDUler selbst. Weil der sitzt natürlich immer da und sagt, das Fassaden an Pinseln hat schon 6 Millionen gekostet. Und dieser Metall-Poller, der den Lkw, der hier nicht vorbeikommt, also hier kommt ja gar kein Lkw vorbei, wir haben ja nichts. Und noch mal 300.000. Das ist virtuelle Politik und das wünsche ich mir von der SPD, weil ich weiß, die SPD würde nicht so ein Föllefanz machen. Sie muss sich nur durchringen, virtuelle Politik zu machen. Irgendwelche Themen gibt es immer und sei es nur so eine, wir probieren es mal, vielleicht gibt es ja doch irgendwann mal Budgets. Und das ist jetzt nächstes kleines Kapitel. Ich verstehe dieses Gefühl in Deutschland nicht so richtig. Also wenn ich Oberbürgermeister von Frankfurt am Main wäre, würde ich dann ein Insta-Video machen zum Thema, ja dankenswerterweise hat der Kanzler mal einen Termin für uns, den Städtetag gemacht und morgen fahre ich hin. Ich bin ganz aufgeregt. Oder würde ich sagen, wann kommt eigentlich der Kanzler? Also wann ist eigentlich der Antrittsbesucher in Frankfurt? Wieso fährt er jetzt erstmal nach England oder was? Verstehe ich nicht. Was hat er mit KSM zu tun? Ich bin doch hier. Ja, ich bin doch der Zampano. Und dieses devote Gefüge von Kommunal- und Bundespolitik, das ist wirklich, ich würde es nicht weiter kommentieren, wir gucken uns das an. Es ist wirklich schlimm, wie es findet. Moment, ich muss gucken, wo es stattfindet. Es findet, ah ja, hier statt. Wir gucken mal so in Kommunen rein, die wirklich auf dem allerletzten Zahnfleisch gehen. Gladbeck zum Beispiel.
Wie in vielen Kommunen im Ruhrgebiet fehlt hier Geld für das Allernötigste. Statt die Aussichtsplattform im Park zu sanieren, sperrt die Stadt sie dauerhaft. Mehr geht nicht. Und auch die Feuerwache, 60 Jahre alt, ist längst viel zu klein. Eigentlich müsste die Stadt eine neue bauen. Stattdessen hat die Bürgermeisterin hier Container stapeln lassen. Dieses Sparen um jeden Preis hat Folgen, glaubt die Kommunalpolitikerin.
Wir hören jetzt Ihr Statement. Ich mache mal eine Alternative dazu.
Wenn die öffentliche Infrastruktur nicht mehr funktioniert, dann verliere ich das Vertrauen in den Staat und hier in dem Fall in die Kommunalpolitik. Wir müssen alle in die Lage versetzt werden, dass unsere öffentliche Infrastruktur intakt ist und unseren Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch in allen Teilen dieser Bundesrepublik zur Verfügung gestellt werden kann.
Ja, wäre doch schön, oder? Und dann gingen sie zurück und warteten, dass etwas passiert. Man könnte auch einfach sagen, ja, also ich habe die Briefe schon gedruckt. Wir laden nächstes Jahr hier zur Feuerwehr-Olympiade. Und es ist ja super peinlich, wie wir das hier zeigen. Also Deutschland wollte euch auf internationale Bühne so blamieren?
Ja, vor allen Dingen hatten wir doch schon einige Kommunalpolitiker, die zurückgetreten sind. In Rheinland-Pfalz gab es den Fall. Und auch in anderen Bundesländern.
Die haben gesagt, es hat keinen Zweck mehr.
Und dann haben die gesagt, es hat keinen Zweck mehr. Wir treten jetzt zurück. Und man dachte eigentlich, mehr würden sich diesem Protest anschließen. Aber so wie das hier vorgetragen ist, gibt es natürlich nur einen Schulterzucken in Berlin. Und man sagt, dann wartet doch noch ein bisschen in Gladbeck.
Ja, wir hören jetzt den Oberbürgermeister von Leipzig, eine Weltstadt. Wenn man in Frankfurt in den Kopfbahnhof einsteigt, kommt man in Leipzig im sozusagen spiegelnden Kopfbahnhof raus. Eigentlich müssten hier echte Connections stattfinden. Man müsste groß auftrumpfen stattdessen.
Wir kollabieren reihenweise, sagt aktuell der Präsident des Deutschen Städtetages, der Leipziger Oberbürgermeister Burkhard Jung. Ich habe ihn heute Nachmittag vor seinem Rathaus gefragt, wie das konkret ist, wenn Städte in die Knie gehen.
Das ist wirklich ernst. Also man bekommt keinen Haushalt genehmigt. Das heißt, freiwillige Aufgaben bleiben auf der Strecke. Kultur, Sportförderung, Vereinsförderung, das alles, was schön ist, sage ich immer, das, wo man gestalten kann, wo man das machen kann, das bleibt auf der Strecke.
Und die Städte sind natürlich gebeutelt von einem Prinzip, das beschreibt er hier auch.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch Kritiker, die sagen, dass zum Beispiel das Finanzierungsmanagement, also die Art, wie Kommunen Kredite aufnehmen, schlicht nicht funktioniert, dass die Kommunen auch eigene Möglichkeiten hätten, mehr Geld einzunehmen und die nicht richtig nutzen. Also müssen sie sich da auch an die eigene Nase fassen?
Das ist das Ergebnis einer Versorgungspolitik, wo wir zum Teil mitgemacht haben, indem wir immer noch was drauf gesattelt haben, Einzelfallgerechtigkeit zu sehr übertrieben haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite wird das große Thema, sind die Sozialausgaben. 48 Prozent unserer Haushalte werden durch Sozialausgaben blockiert. Und bei allem Verständnis, es kann so nicht weitergehen, wir brauchen Hilfe wirklich.
Jetzt kommt ja also ein SPDler, der sagt, ah der Staat, also wir geben zu viel aus, das sind Sozialausgaben, während wir ja immer sagen, nee, sorry, aber wenn in einer Stadt wie Frankfurt 50 Prozent der Leute mehr als 50 Prozent ihres Einkommens pro Monat fürs Wohnen allein ausgeben, muss halt irgendwer diese Rechnungen bezahlen, wenn es die Leute allein nicht können. Woran könnte es liegen? Also wenn man das große Rad dreht, würde man sagen, irgendwas stimmt mit den Arbeitgebern nicht. Ich habe es ja gestern bei Landskorps angemerkt, 100 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum, was ist mit den Löhnen passiert, haben gar nicht mitgezogen. Ja, dann jammert man natürlich über die Sozialausgaben. Nur, was sind Sozialausgaben?
Zu hohe Sozialausgaben, das beklagt auch der Landrat aus Greiz in Thüringen. Er schrieb einen Brandbrief an den Bundesfinanzminister. Kostentreiber seien hohe vom Bund gesetzte Standards. So müsse man etwa für die Betreuung eines stark auffälligen Jugendlichen jährlich 270.000 Euro aufbringen.
Was ist da jetzt der Vorschlag?
Ein Jugendlicher zu betreuen kostet 270.000 Euro. Wenn ich sowas höre, also pro Jahr, wenn ich sowas höre, habe ich tausend Ideen, wie man dieses Problem angehen könnte. Aber nicht, dass man in dieser einen Minute, die man im heutigen Nal hat, weil Winni Heescha mal von den Mini-Merkels sprach, die Vertreter des Städtetags, dann sagen, die Sozialausgaben sind zu hoch. Das ist ein perverses System. Das ist überhaupt nicht zu rechtfertigen, dass das so ist. 270.000 Euro, wenn man das den Jugendlichen geben würde, dann wären die nicht mehr verantwortlich.
Nee.
Problem gelöst? Also das ist wirklich absurd, was hier stattfindet. Und dass die SPD-geführten Städte hier einfach mitjammern, statt einfach zu sagen, sorry, liebe Bundesebene, ihr macht irgendwie ganz komische Gesetze. Das ist total absurd, was hier abläuft. Das ist merkwürdig.
Ja, vor allen Dingen hat ja die SPD das Thema Schuldenbremse schon wieder ganz für sich vergessen. Also die SPD hat das ja nur jetzt für die Aufrüstung auch gut geheißen und fand das jetzt ganz grandios. Dass es doch so gemacht wurde, wie Olaf Scholz mal angedacht. Aber sonst ist das Thema ja für die durch. Also wir glauben doch nicht ernsthaft, dass Lars Klingmer oder so da irgendeinen progressiven Schritt noch macht.
Christian Sievers nennt jetzt hier mal eine Zahl. Und wir rechnen ganz schnell im Kopf 1 plus 1 und wissen danach, wie viele Leute braucht man in Deutschland, wenn es in Deutschland Milliardäre gibt, um dieses Problem aller Kommunen zu lösen?
Den kommunalen Haushalten wird dieses Jahr nach Schätzungen die beispiellose Summe von rund 31 Milliarden Euro fehlen.
Das ist also ein Hobbyprojekt. Das ist gar kein echtes Ernst auf das politische Anliegen. 30 Milliarden ist ein Hobbyprojekt für 60 Leute. Das reicht völlig. Wir sind hier 200 im Saal. Also ich weiß nicht genau, warum da irgendwie die Idee für eine ordentliche virtuelle Politik fehlt, wo man mal ein paar Forderungen stellt.
Aber man könnte ja im Prinzip einfach das Buch von Julia Friedrichs nehmen, das Namensregister am Ende durchgehen und dann könnten wir anrufen.
Jetzt erstickt man einfach an 31 Milliarden, die man mal bezahlen müsste, in einem Land des 10 Billionen. Und wir wissen ja, wie es verteilt ist. Das ist nicht mehr zu erklären. Das ist wie Weihnachtsmarkt. Wir machen mal hier noch ein Licht an und dann leuchtet es schön. Und es ist echt schade, dass der Klopp nach Leipzig geht und so. Das ist alles nicht so. So, wie kann das sein? Vier Clips zu diesem Gefüge aus Bund und Kommunen. Merz gönnerhaft lädt den Städtetag zu sich ein und sagt, ja, ich habe mir Eulkritik angehört, so ein bisschen habt ihr schon recht.
Man wolle zwar, dass der Grundsatz gelten soll, derjenige, der bestellt, bezahlt oder derjenige, der ein Gesetz macht, trägt die Kosten.
Aber wann dieser Grundsatz genau greifen soll, bleibt ungeklärt.
Ja, also das ist schon richtig. Wir machen hier Gesetze und ihr müsst dafür bezahlen. Es könnte ja auch umgedreht sein, dass die Kommunen einfach Gesetze machen und der Land muss, also der Bund muss dann bezahlen. Ginge auch. Aber nein, das ist halt wie es ist. Und ja, irgendwann, keine Ahnung, wir gucken uns das mal an, direkt nachdem wir dann nächstes Jahr die große Rentenreform, die wir der Jungen Union versprochen haben, machen.
Ja, aber du kannst ja vorstellen, wenn die doch beim Städtetag, beziehungsweise die Leute vom Städtetag, auf März treffen und da dann so düsselige SPD-Abgeordnete sind, die dann irgendwas erzählen von 270.000 für auffällige Jugendliche, dann sagt doch Friedrich Merz ja wunderbar, dann holen wir doch gemeinsam den Rotstift raus und legen los. Also der wird ja gar nicht darüber nachdenken, anders die Schulden zu organisieren. Wieso sollte er auch?
Genau. Also das ist alles viel zu einfach für Friedrich Merz, dieses Spiel durchzuspielen. Themen, die auf dem Tisch liegen, wie man Kommunen entlassen könnte.
Wie weit dieses Thema jetzt zukünftig noch besser bearbeitet werden muss, ist eine Frage, die wir zwischen Bund, Ländern und Gemeinden in den nächsten Wochen klären.
Es geht auch um Gesetzgebung wie diese, die Erhöhung der Pendlerpauschale oder die dauerhafte Absenkung der Umsatzsteuer auf Speisen von 19 auf 7 Prozent. Steuererleichterungen, denen der Bundestag heute zugestimmt hat. Sie führen aber auch zu weniger Einnahmen bei den Ländern. Die Zustimmung des Bundesrats deshalb ungewiss.
So, also von Kommunen hört man hier gar nichts mehr. Das sind Bund-Länder-Streitigkeiten und das finde ich immer wieder absurd. Städte wie Frankfurt und sehr viele andere haben Probleme mit Mietverträgen. Und dann heißt es einfach, nee, sorry, Mietvertrag, das ist Zivilrecht, das ist bürgerliches Gesetzbuch, da kann nur der Bundestag was machen. Hier haben wir gar nichts mitzureden und so. Und allenfalls lässt man den Ländern noch mal irgendwas mit durchgehen. Jetzt ist hier also offen. Irgendwas ist mit dieser Gastro-Steuer, irgendwas ist mit Pendlerpauschale und so. Und jetzt hört man noch mal diesen Widersatz zwischen SPD und CDU. Die SPD formuliert es wie folgt.
Ich persönlich kann zurzeit jetzt noch nicht sagen, ob wir eine Mehrheit dafür bekommen, weil es läuft im Bundesratsverfahren und es läuft nach seinen eigenen Gesetzmäßigkeiten. Es wird kommen.
Es ist versprochen.
So, der Herr Schweizer so. Ja, mal sehen, wir machen so ein Verfahren. Mal gucken, das ist eigene Gesetzmäßigkeiten. Die CDU so. Es ist versprochen. Kommt. Da wird die Linie einfach aufrechterhalten, durchgeboxt, als ob Herr Kretschmer irgendjemand aus Sachsen mehr zu sagen hat als der Schweizer. Völlig bescheuert. Na gut, diese Bürgermeister, also jetzt sieht man mal, ich finde das nicht gut. Diese Seegerwohnheit hier, die müssen wir ablegen.
Unter welchem starken Finanzie...
Ich meine, der Städtetag hat einen Termin in Berlin und trifft auf die Bundesebene und die Pressekonferenz findet wo nochmal statt? Das geht doch einfach gar nicht. Also man steht hier irgendwo draußen auf der Straße.
Unter welchem starken finanziellen Druck Länder und Kommunen stehen, wurde heute ebenfalls deutlich. Auch ihre Vertreter waren beim Kanzler.
Ich sag's mal aus dem letzten Loch pfeifen im Bezug auf die Haushalte.
Wir wissen alle, dass es verdammt dicke Bretter sind, die es hier zu bohren gilt. Wir wissen auf der anderen Seite aber auch, dass wir keine Zeit mehr haben, um tatsächlich zu Ergebnissen zu kommen, weil das Wasser im Maschinenraum der Kommunen schon steigt, und zwar bedrohlich ansteigt.
Ja, ihr müsst euch jetzt umdrehen um 180 Grad und mit Anlauf auf dieses Kanzleramt zulaufen, statt irgendwelchen random Journalisten.
Mit denen würde ich auch über alles verhandeln, da wäre man ja immer der Gewinner.
Ja, also, genau. Merz redet mit denen über und kommt dann raus mit, ja, mal gucken, keine Ahnung, wir haben ja andere Baustellen. Und die Kommunen, wie wir wissen, ja, das ist das echte Leben.
Ja, ich mein, Merz hat das ja auch schon von seiner ganzen Haltung her kommentiert. Der sitzt ja so da und sagt dann eigentlich, ich höre mal, ich definiere gerade die ganze Zeit mit Macron und Trump, wer seid ihr eigentlich?
Genau. So, und deswegen, wir müssen uns jetzt, wir haben es schon häufiger thematisiert, Inhalte überwinden. Wir brauchen jetzt ein Mindset, inhaltsunabhängig sozusagen. Und ich habe mir das angeschaut in Wien, falls ihr die Stadt kennt, die sieht flächendeckend so aus. Das ist irgendein kleiner Gang am Rande des Kunsthistorischen Museums, wo man sich so dachte, wir haben zwar noch 50.000 Exponate im Keller stehen, aber lasst doch die Architektur für sich sprechen. Hier steht Form über Inhalt. Wenn man dann achtfach heranzoomt, da steht doch noch so ein Exponat hinten. Aber im Grunde ist das die Rangehensweise. Liebe Touristen, Sie sind hier zu Gast. Das ist nicht das kleine Österreich, das ist das große Wien.
Aber was freut jetzt, da soll man jetzt ganz Dortmund mit Marmor ausstatten?
Nein, ich nehme mir jetzt diese fünf Minuten, uns wirklich die Inhalte auszutreiben. Wir sind jetzt hier im Kunsthistorischen Museum in Wien. Was machen wir mit so einem Gang? Wir laufen ihnen erstmal motivlos entgang. Kommen wir da hinten so an, können rechts und links mal so abbiegen und dann sehen wir so die einzelnen Sachen. Dann hören wir so einen Podcast nebenbei, wo es irgendwie heißt, Trump hat sich wieder bereichert, irgendwas ist mit Bitcoin, keine Ahnung, das ist ja voll das. Und dann sehen wir so, da ist ja nicht der Erste. Also schon längst bevor Jesus Christus geboren wurde, gab es so Mark Anton, wahrscheinlich irgendein römischer Kaiser oder so. So ein Konsul hat sich auch mal so eine Münze machen lassen. Nichts ist neu. Alles, was wir sehen, ist virtuelles Blödsinnstheater. Das kann man auch einfach abhaken. Also man muss gar nicht diese ganzen Podcasts immer hören. Trotzdem schön, dass jetzt Machtwechsel ein eigenständiger Podcast wird. Deutschland ist bewegt von solchen aufregenden Nachrichten. Man geht so ein bisschen weiter. Oh, ein Selfie mit Zeus. Kurzes Gespräch mit irgendwelchen römischen Kaisern. Hat jemand Lust auf einen Kaffee? Hat hier jemand Lust, über Politik zu reden? Nein, wir gehen durch dieses Treppenhaus, setzen uns in dieses Café. Wir haben jetzt schon mal ein neues Main, jetzt so langsam, mehr als dämmert uns irgendwie. Wir können hier nicht Bauzaun hinstellen und sagen, das ist jetzt für immer geschlossen.
Mir ist auch nicht so ganz klar, wie man es nach draußen bringt. Also wir sind jetzt in einem der tollsten Museen Europas, im Kunsthistorischen Museum.
Ja, wir können auch die Straße wechseln. Da sind wir hier im Prunksaal der Nationalbibliothek. Das ist das Google von vor 100 Jahren. Wenn man noch mal wissen wollte, wie setzt man jetzt die Spritze in die Vene und so, dann ist man dahin gegangen und hat nachgeschaut. 80 Meter lang, 30 Meter hoch, da liegen die Partituren von Johann Strauss. Da kann man noch mal mitsingen. Wir haben erlebt, wie da Leute singend reinkommen, weil sie einfach auch mal hören wollten, wie es klingt. Dann wechseln wir nochmal die Straßenseite.
Da kann man noch mal nachgucken, wie es eigentlich komponiert ist und nicht wie André Reiland gespielt.
Ja, genau. Applaus von hier.
Siehst du, da gibt es schon noch ein bisschen Applaus, aber manche sind noch zögerlich.
Die linke Ecke ist meine Ecke und ich kriege Applaus gegen mich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hast du dich schon so lange mal trittiert mit André Reiland.
Nein. Hat hier jemand André Reiland gehört, als er reingekommen ist? Dann warst du leise. Okay, pass auf, wir gehen nochmal über die Straße. Wir sind in der Schatzkammer. Wer kennt dieses Exponat? Alle Hände hoch, sonst erkläre ich es euch. Das ist die Reichskrone. Eins der wenigsten Exponate, wo eine dreistellige Jahreszahl dran steht, 980 oder so. Sie war im Grunde überall. Ich übertreibe nicht, wenn ich sage, das ist wahrscheinlich der bedeutendste Schatz Europas. Der liegt also in Wien einfach so rum. Und man kann ihn dort auch in Aktion sehen. Seht ihr das hier? Kann man sehen? Die Reichskrone auf dem Kopf eines frisch gegrünten Kaisers, der schon seine erste Amtshandlung macht. Er schlägt irgend so ein Proligarchen zum Ritter und sagt, hier du bist es, wo wir einmal alle zusammen sind. Und dann stellt sich heraus, ach ja, genau. Man kann sich ja mal treffen und so. Wir sind also jetzt mitten in der Schatzkammer von Wien. Wir sind von dem tollen kunsthistorischen Museum durch den Prunksaal der Nationalbibliothek in die Schatzkammer gegangen, an der Reichskrone vorbei zu diesem Bild. Wer weiß, was hier zu sehen ist?
Niemand.
Das war klar, das Mary. Ich komme gleich auf Mary noch. Die macht ja tolle Angebote hier. Das ist Frankfurt am Main. Frankfurt am Main ist auch teure Mieten, irgendwelche Brücken in Griesheim, die nicht funktionieren. Der Main, der scheiße aussieht, wenn der Ironman da abgefilmt wird, weil die da langlaufen, was auch immer. Fahrscheine, die 3,80 kosten. Frankfurt am Main, das ist Frankfurt am Main. Frankfurt am Main begegnet uns in der Schatzkammer, am zentralsten Ort, wo uns Europa erklärt wird. Ein Kaiser wird gegründet, ganz Europa ist vor Ort, es werden Amtshandlungen gemacht. Und auch in der Schatzkammer, Stefan Schulz, ich als Tourist und als Dauerding Frankfurt. Das ist Frankfurt. Am zentralsten, historischsten Ort Europas hängt Frankfurt am Main. Haben wir jetzt endlich dieses Mindset so ein bisschen vielleicht? Okay, also hier sieht man eine Versammlung. Der Kaiser wird von rechts nach links, noch nicht Kaiser, fährt also einmal rein, wurde gerade gewählt, fährt einmal rüber, wird gegrönt, kommt wieder raus, die ganze Stadt, die ganze Land, der ganze Kontinent ist versammelt. Goethe schreibt Tagebücher über solche Momente. Mary macht Stadtführung dazu, denn das ist dieser Augenblick, in dem die Welt zusammenkommt und sich denkt, jetzt wo wir einmal hier sind, hast du vielleicht was zu dealen oder so. Dann sagt einer, ja, ich habe hier und so weiter. Also sagt man sich, okay, jetzt wo ihr alle da sind, brauchen wir mal so einen Handelsplatz. Und damit das mit dem Handeln funktioniert, brauchen wir mal so was wie, welches Geld gilt denn gerade? Fragt doch drüben bei der Sparkasse nachher. So gründet man Banken. Man hat diese Verkehrswege. Dieses Bild, die Historie dieses Bildes schleppt sich bis heute. Der Flughafen, die Banken, die Börse, einfach alles, dass die ECB hier steht und so weiter und so fort. Wenn man heute Oberbürgermeister von Frankfurt am Main ist, welches Mindset hat man dann eigentlich für die nächsten drei Jahre, wenn man weiß, man will wiedergewählt werden und die 70-Jährigen drücken irgendwie und haben eh schon 40 Prozent auf ihrer Seite und die Milliardäre und überhaupt und so. Sollte man hier nicht mal grundsätzlich neu denken, was Kommune bedeutet und vielleicht die ein oder andere Forderung und dann eben kreativ unterfüttert, ja wirklich virtuelle Politik, um einfach auch März mal eine Ansage zu machen, wie das hier so zu laufen hat in Deutschland, weil man es vielleicht besser weiß, weil man näher dran ist und so. Und die Frage ist einfach, warum sitze ich bei Markus Lanz und nicht Mike Josef? Ich meine, hier im Hintergrund hat man gestern diese Demografie gesehen und so. Und wir sitzen natürlich dann da und reden irgendwie über Eigentumsverteilung und ein bisschen Daseinsvorsorge und sollte man nicht mal neu bauen für die Familien, für die Omas, wenn auch immer. Wir haben doch hier Planungen, wo es heißt, da kommt die Josef-Stadt hin, weil Mike Josef der Stadtplaner war. Wer hat den Kontakt zu den ganzen Milliardären und so weiter und so fort? Und wovon sieht man einfach gar nichts? Und ich will nicht sagen, dass Mike Josef nicht fleißig arbeitet. Es wird ja super fleißig gearbeitet. Aber da muss so eine Ebene höher, da wo man es halt nicht wegdelegieren kann, was man viel mehr sollte vielleicht, muss virtuelle Politik gemacht werden.
Das müsste aber ja dann eigentlich wirklich bedeuten, dass die mediale Aufmerksamkeit ganz dahin gezogen wird. Denn unser Politikverständnis ist ja so geprägt davon, dass wir Männerpodcasts hören, in denen dann darüber geredet wird, was abends in den Talkshows besprochen wird, und zwar nur Bundespolitik und nichts darüber hinaus. Und dann gibt es so ein, zwei Mal im Jahr so einen bunten Abend bei Markus Lanz oder sonst wo, dass man sagt, wir laden mal Bürgermeister ein. Und hier dann nochmal Christian Sievers ist unterwegs und trifft dann ausgerechnet noch SPD-Bürgermeister, denen nichts anderes einfällt, als Sozialausgaben zu thematisieren, dass diese zu hoch sind. Also das ist natürlich dann auch nochmal das Problem. Aber wie, glaubst du, kann es überhaupt möglich sein, dass die Städte in anderer Weise in den Mittelpunkt rücken und nicht nur irgendwo in den Lokalnachrichten vorkommen, die ja sowieso schon gar nicht mehr so häufig rezipiert werden, weil die Leute diese Tageszeitungen nicht abonniert haben, weil sie sich dann doch so sehr für die Bundespolitik und so wenig für das interessieren, was vor Ort stattfindet.
Also wenn ich Frankfurt wäre, ich war bei Veranstaltungen in der Schweizer Straße, wo man so halb öffentlich, wo sich mal ein bisschen die Superreichen treffen. Und da ist einfach völlig klar, da wird einfach gesagt, ja, also Frankfurt hat heute mal wieder 500 Millionen mehr Gewerbesteuer verbucht, als man vorher schätzte. Also hier fließt ja das Geld. Und ich würde einfach Projekte planen, die trotzdem noch darüber hinaus Geld kosten und dann einfach und das ist dann der kreative Arbeitsteil, der zu machen ist Forderung an die Bundes- und Landesebene. Also die Oper zum Beispiel, unsere Oper. Unsere Oper hat ein Einzugsgebiet der ganzen Welt. Es ist genau mit diesem Wiener Mindset machen wir hier Oper. Und da Boris Rhein hier in Frankfurt schon mal gescheitert ist, als Oberbürgermeister sitzt er natürlich in seiner Staatskanzlei und sagt, ne, Oper Frankfurt, ne, ich sehe das irgendwie nicht. Also das hat mit dem Land gar nichts zu tun. Das ist auch für Deutschland nicht wichtig, wie auch immer. Wir kriegen jetzt in Frankfurt am Main, wir haben gerade wieder Goldmedaillen oder sowas gefeiert beim Schwimmen. Wir kriegen in zwei Jahren, wenn es gut läuft mit dem Regenstoppbad, die erste öffentliche 50 Meter Halle. Selbst in Jena gibt es eine 50 Meter Halle. Solche Sachen verstehe ich einfach gar nicht. Kann man nicht einfach eine 50 Meter Halle bauen? Und wenn dann mal jemand vom Bund aus oder vom Journalismus aus nachfragt und sagt, habt ihr euch da nicht ein bisschen übernommen? Dann sagt man einfach, nein, wir verbuchen hier Goldmedaillen und irgendwo müssten diese Trainingskilometer geschwommen werden.
Ja, ich glaube ja sowieso, eigentlich meine Hoffnung wäre ja eine große Verschwörung. Und zwar der Bürgermeister untereinander, dass sie einfach über gute Juristen sich ausklügeln lassen, wie kann man sich eigentlich mehr verschulden? Und am Ende muss der Bund einfach damit rechnen. Genau, to big to fail, dass man sagt, ach du Scheiße, das haben ja jetzt hundert Städte in Deutschland gemacht. Nicht nur einer, ich meine, wenn es einer macht, dann hat man ein Problem, weil der muss dann gehen und dann wird am Ende noch die Ehefrau belangt oder so, dann muss das Familienhäuschen dran glauben, was auch immer. Aber wenn alle das wirklich machen würden und so Berlin unter erheblichen Druck setzen, wäre das vielleicht ein ganz gutes Vorgehen. Also ich glaube, man kann jedenfalls nicht mehr regelkonform weitermachen.
Nee, regelkonform ist der Untergang. Es muss jetzt alles anders gemacht werden, damit es so schön bleibt.
Mensch, toll. Lieber Ferdinand von Schirach.
Ich habe es aufgepasst und gelernt.
Gehen wir über zum Thema Mensch-Maschine. Es wird schlimm und interessant. Wir beginnen mit Alex Karp. Der ist uns schon ein Begriff. Der hat ja dieses Buch The Technological Republic geschrieben, das wir gelesen haben. Und Stefan meinte dann, das ist so etwa wie mein Kampf.
Auf Deutsch heißt es mein Kampf.
Nur neu.
Mein digitaler Kampf.
Wir haben ihn erlebt jetzt in einem Handelsblatt-Interview. Er mischt sich in die deutsche Politik ein, sagt, hier würde ja mit Technik und so gar nichts mehr laufen. Vor allem geht es ihm auch um die Innenpolitik, die Sicherheitspolitik. Wir hören jetzt im Handelsblatt Morning Briefing Christian Riekens, der zusammenfasst, was so in der Zeitung steht.
Die Reporter Felix Holtermann und Thomas Jahn haben ein ausführliches Interview mit Alex Karp geführt, dem Chef des US-Unternehmens Palantir. Es liefert Sicherheitssoftware unter anderem an die Polizeibehörden in mehreren deutschen Bundesländern. Die Bundesregierung debattiert gerade über die Einführung von Palantir-Produkten. Diese Debatte ist auch notwendig, denn das Weltbild, das Karp im Interview offenbart, ist verstörend, zumindest für all jene, die nicht zu den Sympathisanten von Donald Trump oder Alice Weidel zählen. Vor allem bei der deutschen Migrationspolitik hat sich Karp festgebissen. Hier eine Kostprobe. Ich kann ihnen sagen, was ich machen würde, Grenzen zu und allen, die ohne Pass hier leben, die auch nur auf die entfernteste Art mit Kriminalität zu tun haben, würde ich sagen, hier ist das Flugticket. Ihr habt vier Wochen Zeit, das Land zu verlassen. Danach wird es nicht nett für euch.
Wir merken uns das. So würde er also mit Flüchtlingen in Deutschland umgehen, nicht nur mit Flüchtlingen, generell mit Menschen, die keinen deutschen Pass haben. Das Thema Remigration, all das haben wir hier schon drin bei Alex Karp. Wir kommen ganz am Ende nochmal darauf zurück. Wir haben es also mit einem Mann zu tun, der Überwachungstechnologie verkauft an Behörden, an private Unternehmen, an Städten usw. Der hier über Menschen spricht. Wir schauen uns jetzt, welches Verhältnis er zum Menschen hat und was wir sonst noch für menschliche Verhältnisse vorführen.
Genau, wir müssen das Prinzip nochmal klären. Also wenn Alex Karp und die reden ja sehr viel jetzt öffentlich, wenn die öffentlich reden, dann wissen die, und das ist ja die Peterti-Logik, wir kriegen sie niemals überzeugt mit dem, was wir wirklich denken. Deswegen machen wir es über Technologie. Also selbst wenn wir es jetzt verstörend finden, was Alex Karp öffentlich sagt, eigentlich ist das alles viel schlimmer.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Karp sagt auch Sätze wie, die Migrationspolitik war die dümmste Entscheidung, die je in der deutschen Nachkriegszeit getroffen wurde.
Also jetzt die gesamte Einwanderungspolitik in Deutschland. Falsch gewesen.
Außerdem, und auch dies ist Oth und Karp, im Nahen Osten gibt es mehr Menschenrechte als in manchem Berliner Stadtteil. Mit dem letzten Satz rechtfertigt Karp übrigens, dass seine Firma auch Saudi-Arabien beliefert.
Ja, also das ist sein Weltbild. Ist natürlich auch ganz dabei, wenn es um die Zerbombon von Gaza geht. Da ist auch alles richtig gelaufen in seinen Augen. Dann war er in The Axios Show zu Gast. Da stellte er Palantir einmal selbst vor.
Manhattan, willkommen zu The Axios Show. Your CEO, Co-Founder of Palantir. What the hell is Palantir? Well, it depends who I'm talking to. Well, if I'm talking to you, we are growing the GDP of the US. We are the part of the GDP of the AI economy, where things are useful, either on the battlefield or commercially. And we're the only AI company with a real spread function to the working class Americans.
Working class. Das wird er in dem Interview noch etwa 20 mal sagen, dass sie eigentlich für die working class kämpfen. Er sagt nicht wie, aber er sagt, da ja alle irgendwie sicher sein wollen und auf Technologien zurückgreifen, die sie anbieten, sind sie ja Teil der working class. Auch hier hat er sein großes Thema Sicherheit.
Mein primarisches Problem mit politischen Dingen ist nicht genau und ist etwas unfairer als deine Frage. Ich denke, das primarische Problem für Amerika ist, ob wir eine geschlossene Borderei haben. Ich bin an diesem Punkt ein einzigartiger Voter. Ist die Borderei geschlossen oder ist sie offen? Europa ist ein unmitigiertes Disaster wegen unverfederter, dummer Migration. Von all den Leuten, die du kennst, wer würde den besten Präsidenten machen? Wer ist der nächste Präsident? Der Präsident, der die Borderteile kredibel sagen wird, die Borderteile sind geschlossen, oder es werden die wissenschaftlichen Standards aufgrund von einfachen IQ genutzt werden, Und die Präsidentin, die wirklich, wirklich für die Arbeiter kräftig kämpfen kann. Also, sorry. Das klingt wie der heutige Vizepräsident JD. Vance.
Das ist, ja genau, Vance. Das ist so gut, ne? Also wir haben es ja gestern bei Lanz wieder. 71 fällt diese Geburtenzahl unter diesen Wert. 85, 86 kommt dann irgendwie, die Rente ist sicher und so weiter. Und alle sind schon alarmiert, weil 15 Jahre drunter. Und jetzt sind noch mal 30, 40 Jahre ins Land gegangen. Also Deutschland hätte, nach seinem Wünschen wäre, das sind 64 Millionen Leute statt 83 Millionen in Deutschland. Ja. Und was ist denn dann, gibt es dann eine Working Class, nach so einer Niedergangsgeschichte? Die ist ja beispiellos, gab es ja noch nirgendwo auf der Welt.
Er hat auch da keine Begründung für, sondern er wiederholt es mantra-artig. Sagt er hier auch noch einmal, dass er dafür ist, für den Politiker, der nach IQ geht. Also was er hiermit ja eigentlich sagen will ist, also alles, was irgendwie mal mit Quotierung zusammenhängt. Irgendwas Identitätspolitisches, all das ist Grund daraus abzulehnen. Nur IQ zählt und er wird sicherlich den Allerhöchsten haben. Und dann sagt er ja noch, dass er es ja wichtig findet jetzt, dass egal, wer das ist, dass das angepackt wird. Und das muss man glaube ich auch ernst nehmen. Insofern, als wir hier zwar jemanden haben, der Donald Trump unterstützt hat und der sich jetzt auch gerade in Zeug legt, dass diese Unterstützung sich auszahlt. Nämlich wird er auch von diesem Moderator gefragt, ja, sie sind doch sehr engagiert gegen Antisemitismus. Dann müsste ihnen doch eigentlich Nick Fuentes so gar nicht in den Kram passen, der doch ja zumindest antisemitisches Dogwhistling sehr deutlich betreibt. Und dann zögert er und laviert hin und her, um dann am Ende irgendwo anders rauszukommen, nur um sich nicht mit diesem antisemitischen Teil der Republikaner anzulegen, weil man ja gerade sich von der Trump-Administration noch viel verspricht. Aber wir sollten hier auch sehen, dass Alex Karp, der sich immer wieder als Demokrat begreift und sich ja auch so in seinem Buch vorgestellt hat, durchaus große Anknüpfungspunkte an die Demokraten hat und die auch ja seine Technologien eingeführt haben. Und auch hier in Deutschland ist es ja nicht die AfD, die regiert ja gar nicht irgendwo und ist es auch gar nicht so sehr die CSU, sondern sind es ja beispielsweise die Grünen in Baden-Württemberg, die diese Technologien von Palantir einführen. Das heißt, wir sollten auf keinen Fall jetzt sagen, ah, wir beobachten hier wieder einen Rechten. Es wird viel gespenstischer und viel realistischer, wenn wir hier sehen, hier spricht jemand aus der Mitte heraus. Also der auch sicherlich dem einen oder anderen in Frankfurt, der nicht rechts ist, noch ein Sicherheitsprogramm aufschwätzen kann für die Überwachung des Frankfurter Bahnhofs.
Oder in Quedlinburg für den Weihnachtsmann.
Oder das. Working class. Was ist denn damit so gemeint?
Ich bin ziemlich sicher, dass wir in unserer Infizierung sind. In einem Welt, in dem Palantir 10x 10x größer werden könnte, was bedeutet das für die Person auf dem Fabrikplatz? Wie viel wägen ihre echten Wage? Wenn die Antwort 5% ist, ungefähr bei der Inflation, kannst du sie nicht verletzen, dass sie nicht verletzt werden? Ich denke, der primäre Risiko der AI ist soziale Unstabilität.
Also wenn die SPD keine Sozialpolitik macht, macht sie Alex Karp.
Ja. Und er glaubt, dass weil sein Unternehmen dann 10x DNA hat, um das mal mit Frank Thelen zu sagen, ist er auch derjenige, der sich um die Working Class kümmert. Und die anderen AI-Unternehmen, die machen das nämlich nicht. Aber jetzt haben wir schon gehört, soziale Instabilität. Das ist das größte Problem. Wo sieht er die? Man könnte jetzt an vieles denken. Man denkt ja schon mal nicht an ICE, denn ICE wird auch unterstützt von Alex Karp's Unternehmen. Nächstes woanders.
In welcher Form wird das sein?
Also die Supermärkte, die Mamdani aufmachen will, die sind verrückt. Da muss man die Working Class vorbewahren. Dass die günstig wo was einkaufen können. Ihm geht es um die Rettung Amerikas oder er korrigiert sich. Aber alles ist auch irgendwie dasselbe.
Mathematisch. Also während wir das Thema reden, in der Silicon Valley sprechen sie über den P-DOOM. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die superintelligenten AI so enden werden.
Amerika muss dominanter werden und dann wird die Welt gerettet. Also wenn es 350 Millionen Amerikanern besser geht, geht es den restlichen Milliarden automatisch auch gut. Vollkommen klar. Er ist ein bisschen kulturell spezifisch, aber so ist es zu verstehen. Karp hatte aber auch Emotionen für uns. Wir wissen schon, wir haben ja schon mit Matthias Döpfner geweint, förmlich. Und auch er hat seine Lebensgeschichte aufgeschrieben, aufschreiben lassen. Und auch da muss er uns Emotionen liefern. Also wir haben es mit einem Unternehmen zu tun, das dafür steht, dass man autonom überwachen kann und auch töten kann. Ein Unternehmen, das eigentlich sagt, wir müssen uns so optimieren, dass wir Menschen aushotten können, ohne dass überhaupt noch andere Menschen entscheiden, wer denn jetzt gerade getroffen wird. Das macht alles die KI. Wir haben alle Daten, die man dafür benötigt. Aber dieser Mensch hat natürlich auch Emotionen für uns. Diese Geschichte hören wir nun.
Positiv für dich. Du bist wert von 17 oder 18 Billionen. Aber die meisten Leute verstehen nicht, dass du von sehr wenig hergekommen bist. Du hast mir eine Geschichte über einen Jewelry-Store in Bryn Mawr, Pennsylvania erzählt. Du hast in den Philadelphia-Suburbien gewachsen. Es gab einen Landlord dort, der einen Jewelry-Store gewohnt hat. Es ist in dem Buch. Und ehrlich gesagt, es gibt so viele Geschichten, die ich nicht hätte sagen können. Weil, weißt du, ich weiß nicht. Aber in jedem Fall war meine Mutter total verdammt. Jemand hat ihr geholfen. Ich habe sie zurückgegeben. Und diese Person war ein Landlord, die ihr und ihr ein Ort zu leben gab. Und sie haben noch einen Jewelry-Store. Und wie hast du... Ich kaufe immer noch viel von ihnen. Bis heute. Und was gibt es für andere, die von ihnen lernen können?
Also weiß er, dass ICE gerade eine Anne Frank-Geschichte nach der anderen produziert?
Ja, wenige Menschen helfen. Nur ganz wenige. Und da hat die Mutter totale Glück gehabt. Also man würde ihr eigentlich von dieser Geschichte ausgehend wunderbar über die sozialen Fragen sprechen können. Wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass eine alleinerziehende Mutter plötzlich so vor dem Scherbenhaufen steht, dass irgendjemand sie retten muss, damit sie überlebt? Und der Sohn ist da auf ewig dankbar. Was ist das eigentlich für ein reiches Land, das solche Armut zulässt? Das wäre ja die Frage, die zu stellen ist. Und für ihn ist das aber ganz individualistisch beantwortet. Ja, da hat dieser Mann geholfen, dieser Vermieter und Jubilier. Dem kaufe ich jetzt ein Leben lang irgendwelchen Schmuck ab, aus Dankbarkeit. Also ist ja schön. Nur für ihn resultiert daraus, nur wenige Menschen helfen. Das heißt also, Solidarität ist eh nicht zu erwarten, sondern wo man sie punktuell trifft, dann hat man Glück gehabt und kann es mal ins Buch reinschreiben. Aber sonst gibt es keine Gesellschaft, um es mit Margaret Thatcher zu sagen. Wir hören uns jetzt mal kurz an, wie denn Palantir in der Praxis aussieht. Also wir sehen jetzt hier schon, hier wurden schon mal Emotionen abgeladen, in dem Podcast ausgebreitet, damit wir auch sehen, ach, das ist eigentlich ein ganz feinfühliger Mensch. Ja, mit dieser Überwachung, hat bestimmt Vor- und Nachteile, aber mit der Mutter, das ist doch eine rührende Geschichte. Parallel eigentlich, fast gleichzeitig erscheint ein Interview mit dem UK-Chef von Palantir. Er war bei Bloomberg zu Gast, Louis Mosley, und der wird befragt zu Palantirs Rolle im Krieg in der Ukraine. Denn man steht den Ukrainern zur Seite, oder ist das nicht vielleicht von mir ein bisschen euphemistisch formuliert? Jedenfalls hören wir uns mal an, was hier so der Mensch wert ist, oder wie man ihn betrachtet.
You've worked very closely, of course, Palantir in Ukraine for a number of years since that conflict. What has Palantir learned, what has your team learned by operating, working with Ukrainians, particularly when it comes to the pace of digital transformation on the battlefield?
Ukraine has been the R&D lab for AI in a military context for the last three years. It is the absolute bleeding edge of military technology. There is no substitute for a real battlefield. You can build things in the laboratory, you can test them, but you don't know whether they really work until you've seen it. And Ukraine sadly is where...
Er sagt noch ganz kurz sadly, aber er will eigentlich sagen glücklicherweise......where that is currently happening.
I would pay enormous credit to the Ukrainians here. They have been phenomenally innovative. They're ingenious in many ways. Part of that is circumstance, that they have not had all of the equipment and resources that they would have liked, and so they've been forced to innovate. But that has led to an extraordinary acceleration in military technology, where you're seeing major leaps every six to eight weeks, where tactics and procedures have to change because of some fundamental technological discovery or progress. I think the only historic analogy that I'm aware of is the development of radar during the Second World War, where every bombing raid back and forth across the channel led to some fundamental discovery in radar. You're seeing something similar occur today in artificial intelligence in Ukraine.
Mensch und Maschine, wir sehen da also die Ukraine, also die Soldaten, die da kämpfen und sterben, die optimieren jetzt gerade das Geschäftsmodell, die Software von Palantir. Im Übrigen ist das nicht die einzige Firma, wo so gearbeitet wird. Ich sprach vor ein paar Tagen mit einer Dronenexpertin, die mir erzählte, dass sehr viele Dronenhersteller natürlich die Ukraine beliefern und da ist ja auch Software dabei und dass momentan in unglaublicher Geschwindigkeit Updates durchgeführt werden, was auch manchmal dazu führt, dass dann die Leute dort, also die Soldaten, die nicht richtig bedienen können, aber die Firmen testen jetzt gerade aus, macht man eher mal das oder das, machen A-B-Tests. Ja und die Menschen sind Material in diesem ganzen Unterfangen. Jetzt gehen wir von diesem sehr, sehr bitteren Thema weg und kommen zur Unterhaltung. Denn wir haben jetzt schon gesehen, Emotionen spielen irgendwie eine Rolle, die braucht man auch, um einen Podcast zu füttern, aber man braucht sie auch für die Algorithmen, für die KI, wie wir sehen werden. Oder man kann sagen, in einer Welt, in der immer mehr algorithmisch gesteuert wird, in der immer mehr KI eigentlich die Entscheidungen trifft, ist wiederum interessant, worauf sich die Unterhaltung konzentriert. Sie versucht natürlich auch die Unterhaltungsindustrie, sich durch KI zu optimieren. Aber diesen menschlichen Faktor, den braucht man irgendwie noch, damit es interessanter wird. Wir hören jetzt im OMR-Podcast den Endemol-Schein, also eine Tochterfirma von Endemol, zugehörig zu Bunny J, also diesem ganz großen Konglomerat. Diesen Chef hören wir jetzt namens Fabian Tobias. Der spricht mal über die neueste Showinnovation.
Was war denn die letzte große Innovation, die euch gelungen ist? Also die letzte große neue Fernsehsendung, die man noch nicht vorher gesehen hat?
Das ist definitiv, würde ich sagen, eine Show, die noch nicht on air ist, die wir gerade produziert haben, die so vor vielen Jahren noch gar nicht möglich gewesen wäre. Und du musst dir vorstellen, also stell dir vor Sascha, toller deutscher Sänger.
Was könnte jetzt kommen? I feel lonely, lonely, lonely. Nun, wir haben ja schon in unserem KI-Podcast in Düsseldorf über so einen Fall gesprochen. Da ist eine Mutter, die möchte sich von der toten Tochter verabschieden. Und dann gibt es da so ein Hologramm.
Sitzt auf einer Bühne mit Amy Winehouse und singt ein Song von Amy Winehouse. Neben ihm sitzt Amy Winehouse, die aussieht wie Amy Winehouse und singt wie Amy Winehouse. Ich meine, Amy Winehouse ist ja die Stimme, die ist tot. Und die Stimme ist ja göttlich. Also es ist wirklich eine irre Stimme, die sie hat. Und nicht nur, dass sie Amy Winehouse-Lieder singen, sondern dann gibt es eben auch den Moment, und viel mehr kann ich noch nicht verraten, wo Amy Winehouse mit Sascha I Feel Lonely singt. Und das haben die schon produziert und er redet gerade davon, was auf Halde liegt und es wird gesendet demnächst.
Aber es gab natürlich ein Live-Publikum.
Kopfkino von dir abverlangen. Aber stell dir das mal vor, das ist ein Entertainment-Erlebnis, was wir vor fünf Jahren noch nicht hätten kreieren können, weil es in der Qualität nicht ging.
Warten wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Wir müssen mal gespannt, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, also ich sag mal, funktioniert hat es für das Studiopublikum eindeutig, weil das habe ich noch nicht erlebt. Die Leute, die wir im Publikum hatten, und das sind ja immerhin auch so 500 Leute, die sind ausgerastet. Ich habe zu meinem Team gesagt, das ist eigentlich wie amerikanisches Publikum, dass die gejubelt haben und es geliebt haben. Ach du großer Gott.
Ja, also wir haben den menschlichen Faktor drin. Gucken wir das dann? Ich hoffe nicht. Willst du es gucken?
Oh, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist Podcast-Batrager.
Möglicherweise. Wir behalten es mal im Auge. Jedenfalls auch hier interessant ist, wir brauchen die Emotionen des Publikums. Wir produzieren mit KI jetzt schon Amy Winehouse wieder herbei, aber jetzt die Emotionen des Publikums, die werden da reingegossen.
Ich muss mich revidieren. Ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht. Ich habe eben für virtuelle Politik SPD geworben.
Ach so, weil sie vielleicht Hologrammen losschicken.
Sollten wir das unter inspirativen Gesichtspunkten doch nochmal besprechen.
Aber wie sähe das aus?
Das weiß ich ja noch nicht.
Also könnte irgendwie, dass die SPD sagt, wir machen es nochmal mit Willy Brandt.
Jetzt nicht kleingeistig denken, sondern große Ideen haben. Also sehr gut. Ja, oder?
Oder?
Wir haben einen neuen Bundestagswahlkampf, Willy Brandt gegen Strauß. 2035.
Ja, ich war heute bei der Zahnreinigung und die kamen dummerweise auf Politik. Ich versuche, so was zu vermeiden. Und dann sagte der Zahnarzt ja, früher die Debatten im Bundestag. Und dann habe ich natürlich schon gesagt, bitte sag nicht, bitte sag jetzt nicht Wena und Strauß. Und natürlich sofort ja, Wena und Strauß, das war noch was.
Das werden wir alles nochmal sehen.
Nein, bitte nicht.
Die beiden haben auch noch was zu sagen zum Bürgergild.
Bitte lasst nicht alle wiederkommen. Lasst bitte nicht alle wiederkommen.
Wir haben ja keine neuen. Es macht ja keine ordentliche Politik, der da mal sich auf die große Bühne spielt.
Wie nutzt Endemol-Schein KI?
Ihr nutzt das dann bei Pictures?
Also mit Journey und all diese.
Aber bei Pictures sozusagen.
Genau, also Development. Wir benutzen es aber mittlerweile überall.
Also wir haben es komplett ausgeräut in alle Abteilungen.
Wir haben mittlerweile ein Tool in der Postpro, was einen Vorschnitt macht. Also das heißt, musst du dir vorstellen, wenn du da Unmengen Stunden an Material generierst mit verschiedenen Kameras und so. Bei Big Brother hast du ja zum Teil 30, 40 Kameras und so, dass du dann einen Vorschnitt hast. Also du hast eine KI, die erkennt Töne, die erkennt Mimik, die erkennt Emotionen und schneidet dir das Ganze schon mal vor. Das ist das, was wir gerade testen. Also wir haben das noch nicht ausgeräut, weil das auch ganz, ganz neue Tools sind. Ja, ich kann mir das richtig vorstellen, wie man morgens an seinen Arbeitsplatz kommt. Gestern wurde mit 40 Kameras, 24 Stunden Big Brother gefilmt. Du machst den Ordner auf und die KI hat dir nichts ausgewählt. Alles weg.
Ja, ist ja auch sehr schwierig. Was soll sie auswählen? Also es kann ja nicht um substanzielle Gespräche oder so gehen. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal gehört, dass beim Dschungelcamp gerade substanzielle Gespräche nicht gezeigt werden. Die gab es wohl hier und wieder mal, sondern man will ja ganz andere Nuance plötzlich anbilden. Das ist die Frage, was wir hier aber sehen können. Und das soll jetzt kein Vergleich sein, dass ich sage, die Leute im Big Brother Haus sind, so wie die Ukraine an der Fond. Sondern was ich hier sagen will, ist, dass man den Faktor Mensch hat und dann hat man den Faktor KI. Und die soll jetzt mal so das menschliche Auswerten, was können wir denn da noch optimieren und sehen und verbessern? Und wo dachte man bislang läuft jemand nach links und geht dann doch nach rechts? So geht man hier eigentlich auch vor. Bei den Sprechern ist es auch schon Realität. Er kommt auf diese Sendung Mask Singer zu sprechen. Ich habe das Konzept nicht so ganz verstanden bislang. Ich glaube, da sind Leute in merkwürdigen Kostümen und dann muss man erraten, wer die sind. Ist es so? Ja, es gibt ein heftiges Nicken zum Teil im Publikum. Prima. Wir hören mal, wie da mit Sprechern umgegangen wird.
Wo wir es total schon einsetzen ist bei Stimmen, also Voice-over, also wo man früher Sprecher hatte.
Wir haben jetzt die aktuellste Mask Singer Staffel.
Alles mit KI.
Wie, also diese Moderation aus dem Off zwischen Bits und so?
Diese ganzen Ansagen, die da kommen. Jetzt kommt ein Kandidat, der und so weiter. Das wird alles mit KI jetzt schon gemacht. Westermeyer fragt mal nach diesen Reality-Shows nochmal, warum sind die eigentlich so inflationär überall vertreten?
Reality-Shows, die man früher vielleicht als Trash-Fernsehen bezeichnet hat, seid ihr da auch viel dabei oder macht ja viele Shows, aber auch diese Art von Shows?
Ja, absolut. Und man muss auch sagen, das ist ein Stück weit meine Analyse, dass sich der Produzentenmarkt momentan schon ein Stück weit zweiteilt in die Produzenten, die eine echte Reality-Expertise haben. Die haben noch Wachstumsgeschäft und die Produzenten, die in der Reality blank sind, für die ist es zumindest deutlich schwieriger. Warum? Weil Reality extrem gut im Streaming funktioniert.
Und zwar bei allen Streamern.
Also es funktioniert extrem gut bei RTL+, bei JOIN, bei Netflix und bei Friens Video.
Von den ganzen Sendungen, was ist das? Also alle sind weg?
Die erfolgreichste Streaming Reality ist tatsächlich das Sommerhaus, nicht unsere Produktion.
Sommerhaus der Stars oder das Sommerhaus, keine Ahnung, das junge Publikum ist begeistert.
Eine spannende Message für unsere Branche, die zum ersten Mal mehr im Streaming, also bei RTL+, in dieser Staffel, in dieser aktuellen Staffel, geguckt wurde als linear.
Was gibt es denn noch? Sommerhaus der Stars, es gibt Temptation Island.
Temptation Island, natürlich Kampf der Reality Stars, The 50, Promi Big Brother, Beauty and the Nerd, also das Reality-Feld ist ein sehr diverses.
Und es ist schon, muss man sagen, die Brücke zum jungen Publikum, ganz klar.
Also Reality ist, wenn du mit Jüngeren sprichst, das ist total bei denen gehört zur Popkultur. Die suchten das weg und schließen dafür auch Abos ab. Ja, aber weil es nicht Reality ist, sondern virtuell.
Dazu kommen wir jetzt gleich noch. Da hat diese Renek eine eigene Philosophie. Jedenfalls müssen wir uns das Szenario ja so vorstellen. Wir haben Kameras, die KI gesteuert sind, einen Schnitt, der KI gesteuert ist. Und dann gibt es noch ein paar Redakteure, die das noch mal bündeln für die Show. Also wir haben eine eigentliche Ausrangierung des Menschen. Und zugleich muss aber der Mensch im Mittelpunkt stehen, weil die ganze Zeit ein Publikum da ist, das gerne Menschen in Ekstase sehen will. So bei Promi Big Brother.
Also Promi Big Brother ist die größte Reality. Das war jetzt die erfolgreichste Staffel seit vielen Jahren.
Gerade gelaufen.
Und woran lag es, weil auch große Namen dabei waren?
Ja, also wir haben, also auch da, ich sehe das natürlich mit so einem strategischen Blick, dass es für mich so wirklich an alten Marken zu arbeiten. Wir haben auch bei Promi Big Brother irre viel auch verändert und haben die Geschichten nochmal neu aufgezogen, haben das Moderationskonzept verändert, haben einfach an dem Format wirklich hart gearbeitet. Und am Ende ist es uns gelungen, einfach irre unterhaltsame Geschichten zu erzählen.
Natürlich hat Desiree Nick und Harald Glööckler auch geholfen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es mitbekommen hast, aber die haben halt die Show auch ein Stück weit gerockt.
Wie lange waren die jetzt eingesperrt dann da?
Die waren jetzt zwei Wochen eingesperrt.
Ist das immer noch ein Wahnsinn eigentlich?
Das war jetzt so ein Moment von Westermeyer, wie die Partitur zu lesen und zu weinen. Also er hört einfach das Konzept, dass die beiden da eingesperrt sind und flippt schon aus. Das erste Opfer für Endemol.
Ja, Matrix, den Film kennen wir alle, aber wir haben uns doch vielleicht doch immer gefragt, ob das so ganz plausibel ist. Warum brauchen überhaupt diese Maschinen? Warum brauchen die überhaupt noch den Menschen? Denn man könnte ja sagen, die sind doch so übermächtig. Was haben die dann überhaupt noch mit uns verloren? Aber die spielen ja schon eine existenzielle Rolle für die Maschinen. Und die Erklärung bekommen wir dann geliefert, hier in einer berühmten Szene. Wir hören mal rein.
Die Menschlichkeit erzeugt mehr Bio-Elektrisen als eine 120 Volt-Batterie und über 25.000 BTU-Elektrisen im Körperwettbewerb. Verbunden mit einer Form der Fussion Die Maschinen haben alle Energie, die sie brauchen würden, gefunden. Es gibt Flüsse, unendliche Flüsse, wo Menschen nicht mehr geboren sind.
Die Menschen werden nicht mehr geboren, sondern gezüchtet. Und wenn man sich die Reality Stars ansieht, hat man mitunter wirklich den Eindruck. Aber Spaß zur Seite, warum es eigentlich jetzt hier geht, ist zu sagen, ja, das mit dieser Energie war immer so ein bisschen diffus. Man dachte also, die brauchen so Energie. Batterien gehen nicht oder sind nicht so effektiv wie die menschliche Energie. Aber wenn wir es wirklich so sehen, also das menschliche Verhalten auszulesen und die menschlichen Emotionen auszuschlachten, dann sind wir, glaube ich, auf dem richtigen Trip. Und dann ergibt Matrix Sinn. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal einen Eindruck davon vermitteln, was zum Beispiel bei Promi Big Brother passiert, dann sind das ja solche Aufeinandertreffen von Menschen. Das ergibt dann eine Sendung. Das ergibt aber auch wiederum Clips, die in den sozialen Medien viral gehen und die Algorithmentonen ihr übrigen.
Darf ich noch einen Witz machen?
Ja, bitte.
Das ist die Kommunalpolitik in fünf Jahren, wenn es so weitergeht.
Die wird dann gezüchtet oder du würdest sagen, das ist die Kommunalpolitik.
Das ist ein Mensch, das ist die Maschine, Energie.
Ja, ja oder Kommunalpolitik als Big Brother House, wäre auch interessant. Nun einen kurzen Clip, der auch dann viral gegangen ist. Desiree Nick streitet sich mit Doreen Dietel. Es geht darum, dass Doreen Dietel Farbe, Creme oder Joghurt unter dem Auge hatte. Ich weiß es selbst nicht so genau, aber es sorgt auf jeden Fall für Anne klar.
Bei dir fand ich blöd, dass du den blauen Joghurt unterm Auge hast. Da dachte ich, ich nehme die. Du hast doch blauen Joghurt unterm Auge gehabt. Na ja, aber es hilft doch nicht. Hör doch auf mit dem Joghurt. Warum sagst du denn, es war Joghurt gestern? Du hast gesagt, du hast Joghurt aus dem Tränensack.
Du hättest auch mit dem Kopftuch, wie so eine alte Huma.
Das mache ich extra. Ein Kopftuch ist ein Kopftuch, der heißt, es ist Kopftuch.
Selbstassistin, ha ha ha.
Weil ich eine völlig unheitle Person bin. Ich mache mich gerne zum Obst.
Zum Löffel.
Da weiß ich doch, dass ich mit einer rede, die einen an der Waffe hat. Es tut mir leid.
Das sind die Emotionen, die produziert werden. Und dann können sie in die Kanäle hinaus.
Diese Sendungen werden jetzt durch KI besser.
Nein, nur der Schnitt wird nicht besser, sondern einfacher, billiger. Das braucht man ja. Also genau das ist nicht zu ersetzen. Also wie die Ukrainer auf dem Felde kämpfen müssen, das ist nicht zu ersetzen. Müssen die schon da rein. Die müssen schon zwei Wochen eingesperrt werden.
Aber die Kameramänner müssen nicht mal mit eingesperrt werden.
Die Kameramänner müssen nicht mehr irgendwas machen. Und im Schnitt macht das auch die KI. Also das heißt, man hat den Menschen nur noch so als Energie. Träger da und kann ihnen aussaugen. So auch hier die große Frage, die du ja schon aufgemacht hast, ja, ist das Realität? Nein, das ist die Inszenierung von Realität oder was auch immer. Desiree Nick streitet sich mit dem Schauspieler Michael Naseband.
Inszenierungen, Shows, Theater.
Du inszenierst dich doch auch.
Hier doch nicht.
Du inszenierst dich doch hier selber auch.
Nein, wo denn?
Das ist ja nicht die Desiree, die zu Hause arbeitet.
Natürlich.
Um mich einordnen zu können. Das ist zum Scheitern verurteilt, wenn du mich nicht einmal auf der Bühne gesehen hast.
Also sie, das ist eine interessante Argumentation. Erst wenn du mich auf der Bühne gesehen hast, wirst du wissen, wer ich bin.
Moment.
Nein. Ich tanze nicht, ich singe nicht. Es ist keine Inszenierung, die kann nur vorgenommen werden.
Du inszenierst dich selbst.
Hör doch mal bitte zu.
Ich hör dir die ganze Zeit zu.
Du hörst nie an.
Du lässt mich ja nie sprechen.
Ja, weil es so ein Schwachsinn ist.
Das ist in deinem Auge ein Schwachsinn, aber nicht in meinem Auge.
Wenn das das Spektrum ist. Hör mal zu.
Der Schreit hat nicht recht, diese Repetition. Wer laut wird, hat nicht automatisch recht.
Er hat mir vermitteln wollen, dass ich nur hier bin und gebucht bin, um andere Menschen zu diskriminieren, klein zu machen, zu erniedrigen und fertig zu machen.
Ich höre immer zu. Nur dir höre ich nicht immer zu, weil du mit Wortbösen sprichst und nicht weißt, was du eigentlich sagen willst. Du willst nur laut sein und das gegenüber Mund tot machen. Das willst du machen.
Das ist so was, Külis. Du hast so einer wie du, hat Leute eingebuchtet und deren Leben verändert. Gefährlich, gefährlich, gefährlich.
Ich will sich immer wieder auf die Politik zurückbinden, aber ich sehe hier Carsten Lennemann, der im Morgenmagazin erklärt, dass das wirklich ernst gemeinte, der echte Politik ist, die die CDU da macht. Und wie kommen Sie darauf, dass das ist doch nur Ihre Meinung? Also wir machen doch hier echte Politik. Es geht auch um echte Milliarden.
Ja. Also als ich überlegte, was ich heute mitbringe, hatte ich natürlich Karp-Interviews noch und nöcher gehört. Und ich hatte aber auch schon längere Zeit so was festgestellt, nämlich dieser menschliche Faktor, der überall kommt. Also wir kennen ja sowieso dieses Phänomen der Katzenvideos. Ja, ach wie goldig, was sie da machen. Aber wir sehen das ja auch bei Menschen. Man startet so drauf und denkt, was machen die denn da? Das ist interessant. Und mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass immer mehr Sendungen so produziert werden, dass man einfach sagt, wir stecken Menschen zusammen und gucken mal, was passiert. Und das gibt es aber nicht nur als Reality-Show, sondern auch als Samstagabendshow oder als Comedy-Show. Ich würde auch hier haben wir noch einen Diskurs wirklich über Inszenierung und Authentizität. Es gibt aber auch schon Formate, die würde ich jetzt unter das Motto stellen, Menschen, die Laute von sich geben. Und da gab es beispielsweise für den Sommer, ich hatte mir diese Show gemerkt und bring sie jetzt mit, da gab es für den Sommer eine extra Ausgabe von Caroline Kibikus, Camping. Dort waren diese Leute, diese Wolters zu Gast. Das sind so zwei, ich weiß auch nicht, Moderatoren, sage ich mal vorsichtshalber. Und noch irgendeine Comedian. Wir hören jetzt einfach nur mal, wie so geredet wird, was so von sich gegeben wird.
So, Peter, wir haben auch einen Urlaub zusammen. Olof! Olof!
Lass uns rübergehen.
Boah, guck mal, der Fahrt dauert nicht so lang.
Ich glaube, wir sind nur ins Berge.
Guck mal, oh, die Stühle gehen mir ein 70er-Weil.
Du bist hier?
Ich quetsche mich an dir vorbei.
Ah, ist das schön. Hier, ein schönes Wasser.
Auf den Olof! Auf den Streiten, okay?
Ja! Hört mal Frieden, nicht so viel Streiten.
Nicht so viel Streiten, das ist das Wichtigste.
Cheers!
Arbeiten!
Was macht das mit dir?
Ja, also dieser Tisch, dieser Tisch wäre so einladend, um dann wirklich die Axt dabei zu haben.
Ja.
Die Fernsehgeschichte nochmals.
Ja. Wir hören aber noch zwei Clips daraus, weil ich will wirklich sagen, das war jetzt nicht einfach zufällig irgendwo rausgegriffen, sondern das ist die Sendung. Es gibt irgendein Spiel, da soll was erraten werden. Ach nee, da soll jetzt irgendjemand, der soll jetzt voll geladen werden mit irgendwelchen Sachen, die er tragen soll, bis er nicht mehr tragen kann. Und wir hören auch hier mal nur darauf, was so viele Laute von sich gegeben werden. Mann, das kann ich jetzt ja nicht auch sagen.
Wenn ihr jetzt noch mal ein warmes Pfeil, aber fällt ja gar nicht. Es fällt ja gar nicht.
Es stabilisiert ja sogar noch.
Äh, okay, jetzt sagt das jetzt nicht.
Der Schirm, der Schirm.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht der Schirm.
Auf jeden Fall der Schirm.
Der Baumstamm oder, oder?
Der Baumstamm?
Nein, den Stein.
Wir haben ja einen Baumstamm.
Der Stein.
Der Stein. Wir haben einen Stein.
Hat so wenigstens zu tun, als wenn er schwer wäre.
Wenn, ich weiß nicht, wie wir das machen.
Wir haben eine Lösung gefunden. Oh nein.
Das ist nicht der...
Ihr macht jetzt den Baumstamm.
Genau. Den Baumstamm. Mit Teller?
Der hoffentlich genau so schwer ist wie der Stein. Mit Teller. Oh fuck, der ist schwer. Der ist wirklich schwer.
Oh Gott.
Oh mein Gott.
Moment.
Tut mir leid.
Der ist nicht schwer. Es ist was runtergefallen.
Das, das, das gute Konflikt.
Oh nein, damit hat Team Deadlift gewonnen, will ich sagen.
Also Menschen, die, ja, da gibt es schon Applaus, aber es gibt noch einen Clip, keine Sorge. Also Menschen, die was von sich geben und es fließt zu den Maschinen. Also die KI guckt sich das an, wertet es aus, guckt, was kann man dann noch optimieren? Welchen Clip kann man daraus basteln? Für Social Media noch einen letzten kurzen Clip aus dieser Sendung. Menschen, die laute von sich geben. Tuch suchen.
Ah, das Wasser ist abgelaufen.
Ja, die Dusche ist ausgegangen, aber ich war noch eingeschollen.
Er hat im Kino.
Bestseller Auto.
Vielleicht ist das auch die Zukunft der Menschheit. Dass wir einfach nur noch so irgendwelche Geräusche von uns geben und wir schauen, was die Maschine damit macht. Ist aber nicht das Einzige, was man beobachten kann, sondern auch, wo es um diesen menschlichen Faktor geht, der Laber-Podcast. In dem es ja so ist, dass zwei Leute zusammensitzen und loslabern, ohne sich irgendwie vorbereitet zu haben auf etwas. Das gibt es ja in den privaten Medien. Ja, es gibt die Kaulitz Hills mit Spotify, die Kooperation oder die Spotify-Kooperation mit vielen anderen, die sowas machen. Aber interessanterweise, und ich frage mich ehrlich gesagt, warum gibt es das jetzt auch beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, dass das Öffentlich-Rechtliche jetzt auch gerne Laber-Podcasts groß machen will und deshalb Leute engagiert, wie zum Beispiel Hannes und Jeremy, die machen einen Podcast, der heißt Adoptivbrüder. Da sitzen die einfach so da und reden. Wir wollen uns mal einen Eindruck davon vermitteln lassen, worum geht es da und fragen uns auch, ist es überhaupt sinnvoll, dass das Öffentlich-Rechtliche da noch mal sagt, wir nehmen Geld in die Hand und lassen die das machen?
Worte von Masturbieren. Heißt es bei Männern auch so? Natürlich, Masturbieren ist der allgemeine Begriff. Würde ich jetzt einfach mal so sagen, die Redaktion ist da immer mit Fake News kritisch, aber da bin ich mir recht sicher. Bin ich ein großer Fan davon. Und ja, machst du eigentlich immer jeden Abend und so? Gestern war ich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben und vorgestern abends im Bett und hatte keinen Bock. Hä? Und ich mache mir richtig Sorgen. Zwei Tage am Stück. Ich habe gestern dann trotzdem gewichst. Aber ich hatte keinen Bock. Und das hatte ich noch nie. Ich lag noch nie abends nach einem langen Tag im Bett, weil das ist für mich immer das Schönste. Ich komme runter, ich bin so, dann kann ich gut schlafen.
Ja, ich hatte gestern Sex.
Scheint für dich.
Ja, habe ich gemacht.
Wow. War entspannt. Wie war es?
Gut.
Konntest du überhaupt?
Ja.
Aber manchmal, es gibt auch so müde Ficks. Da liegt man so auf der Seite und hat so das ganze Körpergewicht auf dem Bett drauf und bewegt nur so seine Hüfte. Checkst du? Hört sich nach einer richtig wilden Session von der Dame. Echt wilde Session, egal. Einfach so seitlich rein.
Wie kann das sein? Also, wie kann das sein?
Ich glaube, das ist Trainingsmaterial für die Maschinen.
Oder?
Um das, was die Menschen noch ausmachte, noch mal kurz zu hören.
Ja, oder? Also, es kann nur wie im Matrix-Szenario sein. Warum das öffentlich-rechtlich gefördert wird, ich weiß es nicht. Zumal die Leute jetzt, die das da machen, kein Geld brauchen. Sie verkünden dann in einem Podcast nämlich in einer Folge, dass sie nun eine Million auf dem Konto haben. Sie haben nämlich eine App entwickelt, mit der man so Handyspiele spielen kann oder was auch immer. So Partyspiele, keine Ahnung. Berichten sie auch von.
Okay.
Hey Leute, ihr fragt euch, warum dieser emotionale Anfang? Jeremy, sagt es euch. Leute, heute ist ein glorreicher Tag, der Geburtstag eines jeden Geschäftsmannes. Vor 15 Minuten habe ich erfahren, dass wir eine Million Euro auf dem Konto haben. Das sagst du jetzt so langweilig. Das war immer so ein Traum von uns. Eine Million, so schwarzer, weiß, 6 Nullen. Und ich habe das heute morgen gesehen und Jeremy hat irgendwie keinen Zugang zu unserem Banking, deswegen sieht er nie, was abgeht. Und dann habe ich es ihm so gezeigt und das war ein toller Moment. Das war irgendwie, Bro, also, respectfully mit 21, eine Million Euro ist schon crazy. Also es ist wesentlich, also es ist so, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe, muss man fairerweise sagen, es ist so, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Ja, aber diese eine Million jetzt auf seinem Konto hat genau 6 Nullen. Das ist ja wie ein Lotto-Gewinn.
Toll.
So ist es, also, ja, okay. Ich frage mich auch, das ist heute auch eine Lügen-Geschichte.
Warum spricht man so? Also ich kenne ja nun auch viele Leute in diesem Alter, aber die sprechen nicht so. Vielleicht strengen sie sich an, wenn sie mit mir reden. Das kann natürlich sein.
Ja.
Aber hier ist ja nicht ein einziger klarer Satz.
Ja. Vielleicht weißt du einfach nicht, wie erschöpft die Leute immer sind, nachdem sie fünf Minuten mit dir geredet haben. Drehen sich so weg und...
Das gibt es aber auch in der weiblichen Ausführung. Es gibt einen auch Funk-Podcast, der heißt Bramwe Mädchen.
Oh, Reihe 1, der kennt das schon.
In Reihe 1 schon erste Kurz vor der Ohnmacht. Wir hören auch da mal rein, was diese beiden Damen uns zu berichten haben.
Jeder Promis, dem ich jemals in die DM gesellt bin, jeder hat mir geantwortet, jeder ist darauf eingegangen. Jeder. Bei mir und der Liebe läuft es so gut. Es läuft so gut. Es läuft so gut. Also, basically gibt es da so einen kleinen Underground-Sänger. Wir haben überlegt, ihm in die Instagram-DM zu schreiben, weil Henna, du bist actually die delusional one, weil du immer sagst, ich habe hundertprozentige Chancen. Bin ich delusional oder bin ich real? Jeder Promi, ja.
Ja, bin ich delusional oder real? Wer mag es wissen? Wie läuft so ein Date ab? Auch so was wird dann hier ausgiebig verhandelt. Also, wir können natürlich immer nur so kleine Eindrücke vermitteln. Aber ich kann sagen, ich habe vieles gehört und es ist immer so. Also, es ist nicht so, dass sie dann nachher über ein Buch reden oder so.
Weil der liebt saufen, der liebt Party machen, so. Und Paul hat mir Dr. Promille vorgestellt. Dr. Promille hatte in der Show eine Dame kennengelernt.
Also, Dr. Promille scheint irgendein Pseudonym zu sein für jemand, den man nicht nennen will, weil er auch in der Öffentlichkeit steht.
Und die zwei waren zusammen auf einer Party mit mir auch. Wir haben uns alle zusammen kennengelernt, blablabla. Alles cool. Ich habe gesehen, die sind miteinander. Kein Ding so, ne? Wir haben uns gut verstanden. Dieser Mann, Dr. Promille, der ist ultralustig. Der ist der witzigste Mann leider, den ich kenne. Du kennst ihn auch sehr gut. Der ist einfach lustig. Ganz viele hier werden wissen, um wen es auch geht. Der ist einfach sehr witzig.
So und dann, wenn man manchmal mit dem Regionalexpress fährt und die Schule ist aus, dann hat man oft solche Gespräche. Und ich so, ne boah echt? Und der so ja. Jetzt aber hier öffentlich rechtlich gefördert.
Ein paar Wochen oder so irgendwann schreibt er mir ja, ob ich vorbeikomme auf irgendeine Hausparty und so. Ich so ja voll, dann quatsch ich mit dem, der erzählt mir, ja es hat nicht geklappt mit der. Die sind jetzt nicht mehr zusammen und was weiß ich. Dann ich natürlich, wie ich bin, GV am ersten Abend, wie es ist. Let them know. Ja, let them know. Dann, weißte ich, weiß gar nicht, ob ich dir das jemals erzählt hab, wir sind nämlich in ein Hotel gefahren für GV. Und dann sind wir, am nächsten Tag bin ich halt gegangen, der wollte noch mit mir brunchen gehen. Warum seid ihr in ein Hotel? Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt grad nicht mehr. Ich weiß es noch mal. It's giving vergeben.
Einkommen. Was muss eigentlich ein Mann verdienen, der bei diesen Frauen landen will? Auch dazu äußern sie sich.
Einkommen, Minimum 50.000 im Monat. Mein Realist. Ja, ich hab wirklich nachgedacht, wie viel ein Mann verdienen müsste, damit ich ihn date. Da hab ich beschlossen, mindestens 35.000 Euro Netto im Monat. Ausnahme mein Ex. Will ich als Joke-Bachelorette werden, weil ich will, dass da 20 Hansel um mich kämpfen, während ich aber gar keine Beziehung will. Du als Bachelorette. Mein Bachelorette müsste dann so sein, ja.
Ja, 35.000 Netto.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt müssen wir einen Clip überspringen. Es ist so vulgär, dass ich es hier nicht spielen will. Und wir haben auch Minderjährige. Wir haben Minderjährige hier im Publikum. Wir spielen es nicht. Ich sage nur, was es ist. Es ist aus dem Edel Talk Podcast mit Papa Platte und die und Rhys und die unterhalten sich da über sexuelle Dinge und das Wir spielen es nicht.
Aber ich will nur kurz anmerken. Eigentlich schiebe ich dann immer die Dinge in der Playlist darunter. Dieses Schieben funktioniert gerade nicht. Vielleicht wollen die Maschinen uns irgendwas sagen.
Vielleicht. Ja, vielleicht wollen sie, dass wir spielen. Wir spielen es nicht.
Nein, wir spielen es nicht.
Es ist einfach unfassbar vulgär. Was wir aber spielen, ist, dass in dieser Show, in der sie auch nur dummes Zeug reden, also Wiens und Papa Platte, auch eine Produktion von Funk, in dieser, in einer Folge konnten auch Hörer sich per E-Mail melden und Fragen stellen. Und die meisten stellen irgendwelche Sexfragen, die dann suffisant beantwortet werden. Aber es gibt eine wirklich interessante Hörerfrage und auf die hat mich ein Hörer unseres Podcasts hingewiesen. So bin ich überhaupt drauf gekommen. Und wir hören uns erst mal diese Frage an. Denn man könnte ja sagen, bei all dem Stuss, der da so geredet wird, vielleicht haben sie ja doch uns irgendetwas Interessantes mitzuteilen. Zumindest ihrer Community, die ja offenbar einen Bezug zu diesen Leuten hat.
Okay, dann klicke ich jetzt nicht auf den Clip, wo Sex-Talk steht, sondern Hörerpost.
Richtig, ja.
Doppelblöff, wenn der wirklich Felix heißt, aber alle denken, es ist sein Fake-Name.
Hab ein bisschen ein Problem. Ich bin jetzt 25 Jahre alt und bin an dem Punkt im Leben angekommen, den viele als das Hamster-Rapper schreiben würden.
Warte mal, ist das Philo?
Ja.
Fuck, okay.
Ich habe einen Job, den ich ganz gut erledige, aber verdiene deutlich weniger Geld als mein Umfeld.
Meine Freundinnen um mich herum, sorry, nicht meine Freundinnen, sondern meine Freunde, meine Freunde um mich herum verdienen nicht nur mehr Geld, sondern bilden sich noch weiter, fangen an zu investieren und kriegen noch Geld gespart. Seit dem Auszug in eine eigene Bude ist es noch extremer geworden. Ich gehe arbeiten und komme geradezu über die Runden, kriege kein Geld wirklich gespart und habe Schiss, dass ich hier auf der Strecke bleibe. Ich bin sicherlich nicht alleine mit den Gedanken. Danke, Kuss.
So, ein Thema, das wir ganz lange hier schon im Podcasts behandeln. Wir wissen, dass ist eine ganz große politische Dimension, die hier angesprochen wird. Das ist nicht eigentlich individuell zu lösen. Man müsste also, wenn man sich auf diese Frage bezieht, genau das Politische mit hineinbringen. Wir müssten dann zum Beispiel über die Reallöhne sprechen. Wir müssten über hohe Mieten sprechen. Wir müssten über eine Situation sprechen, in der nur derjenige, der zahlungskräftig ist, gesellschaftlich entsprechend partizipieren kann. All das müsste man ansprechen. Jetzt hören wir mal, wie die Antwort von Rees und Papa Platte ausfällt. Und wir hören die in mehreren Teilen. Und auch da habe ich schon gekürzt, denn die reden über zehn Minuten wiederholend im Prinzip immer das Gleiche. Aber wir versuchen uns dem mal zu nähern. Denn erstmal vielleicht mal in Eindruck, es gibt noch irgendeinen Ansatz bei denen da. Vielleicht kommt noch irgendetwas.
Also 25 Jahre ist jetzt mal aus Leben gerechnet eigentlich noch Küken. Noch sehr, sehr jung. Trotzdem finde ich, das ist ein Thema, wo wahrscheinlich viele sich auch drin wiederfinden können, ein Stück weit. Und deswegen All Gags Aside. Ich weiß nicht, wir sind eigentlich so ein Hihihaha lustig lustig Podcast. Aber gerade in dieser Sache, da finde ich, kann man die YouTube-Kommentare doch mal richtig gut benutzen. Das sei jetzt nämlich zum Beispiel, wenn ihr es gerade zuhört und ihr findet euch darin ein bisschen wieder, ihr habt Erfahrungen damit oder habt euch vielleicht aus dem Hamsterrad rausgekämpft mit dem Horst und Hopf Podcast zum Beispiel, dann könnt ihr einfach mal in die Kommentare gehen. Ich gehe wieder auf Ernst, schreibt doch mal rein, weil ich glaube, diese Person hier.
Also das mit Horst und Hopf war ironisch gemeint, aber das meint er jetzt ernst.
Wir wissen nichts, also Felix hier in dem Fall. Unser Felix, vielleicht wird das dem ja auch helfen, wenn er unter der Folge jetzt ein bisschen sieht, hier schreibt irgendeiner, ja, bei mir ist das auch oder bei mir war das. Und ich habe dann das und das so und so gemacht. Ihr könnt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen austauschen, fände ich toll.
Ja, schreibt es in die Kommis, die alte Influencer-Weisheit, dann habe ich nichts mehr damit zu tun. Ja, ja, also man erledigt sich dem einfach. Man könnte ja jetzt mal darüber nachdenken, warum ist die Situation eigentlich so? Vor allem könnte man ja sich überlegen, wenn Felix jetzt den ein oder anderen Ratschlag, der jetzt noch kommt, befolgt, also nicht mehr in dem Job dann ist, ist der Job dann verschwunden oder muss ihn einfach nur ein anderer machen?
Ja, ich glaube, das Problem ist halt gerade so dieses, was jetzt hier dieser Felix sagt, also wir nennen ihn Felix und ich glaube, er heißt nicht Felix, aber das ist der Doppelblöff. Ich glaube, das Problem, was hier ist, ist, er kann gerade so über die Runden kommen und hat dann halt nicht so Zeit, um sich noch weiterzubilden. Das heißt, er kann halt nicht hingehen und einen höheren Bildungsgrad erreichen, weil dafür gar keine Zeit ist, weil er ja arbeiten muss, um gerade so über die Runden zu kommen.
Denn wir wissen ja, wenn alle einfach einen höheren Bildungsgrad erreichen würden, dann gäbe es ja die anderen Jobs nicht mehr, die schlecht bezahlt sind. Das ist ja logisch. Es müssten einfach nur alle Chefärzte sein, dann wäre die Pflege auch nicht mehr so unterbezahlt.
Aber grundsätzlich die Frage, ob das überhaupt ihm helfen würde, mehr Geld zu verdienen. Das ist ja auch nicht gesagt.
Gut, kann man argumentieren.
Weil wir wissen ja nichts. Wir wissen nicht, in welcher Branche er ist, in welchem Job er ist.
Ich meine, wäre es nicht grundsätzlich mal ein Ding, also ich bin zu unemployed mein Leben lang gewesen, um das jetzt zu sagen, aber ist es nicht allgemeine Idee, mal den Job einfach zu wechseln?
Ja, ja.
Ja, oder?
Es ist, was soll man dazu sagen? Ihr kennt ja alle diesen Fragrance-Clip mit, wenn du nur 1000 Euro machst, musst du halt 2000 machen.
Ja, ja, also sie machen sich über Ross und Hopf lustig, aber sie sagen im Prinzip auch nichts anderes als die zwei. Sie haben dann wenigstens noch ein Krypto-Ding, das sie verkaufen können.
Ich weiß jetzt zum Beispiel nicht, hättest du dir vielleicht, wenn du ein anderes Umfeld hättest, hättest du vielleicht dir eine andere Wohnung geholt, eine günstigere Wohnung geholt, die dich vielleicht dein Budget nicht noch so on top strapaziert oder sowas. Das weiß ich halt.
Hat er gesagt, ich hab mir eine überteuerte Wohnung geholt? Nein, er hat geschrieben, dass er von zu Hause ausgezogen ist und seitdem drückt die Miete noch so sehr.
Ist auch eine tolle Idee, dass man sich das mit der Wohnung so aussuchen könnte.
Ja.
Ah, die 4.500, ich nehme die 4.350.
Ja, gerade in Berlin, da kündigt man mal schnell den alten Mietvertrag und nimmt sich dann eine günstige neue. Ja, genau so ist das.
Das lese ich jetzt hier nur so raus, ja. Boah, aber was gibt man jetzt so jobmäßig als Tipp? Also, ich denke, wenn das jetzt wirklich...
Vielleicht ist es ein Ding, mal so im Freundeskreis zu fragen. Also ich glaube, so mal zu gucken, so vielleicht kann da jemand, also ich weiß nicht, je nachdem, wie halt der Freundeskreis ist, aber so, ich glaube grundsätzlich mal zu fragen, ey, Leute, ich überlege gerade irgendwie so den Job zu wechseln und vielleicht könnt ihr euch mal umhören oder so. Vielleicht habt ihr ja irgendwas fertig, vielleicht habe ich was rein. Also allgemein so ein bisschen die Connections versuchen so zu playen, das glaube ich immer gut.
Ja, Connections playen und true. Also diese Leute sind völlig blank. Also wenn die nicht über Pippi-A-A-Witze lachen oder sie selbst machen, dann kommt einfach nichts. Das ist die absolute Holheit hier auf 90 Minuten jede Woche.
Ich glaube, was auch wichtig ist, ich, ich bilde mir das ein, hier so ein bisschen auch rauszulesen, weil er ja auch so sagt, so Hamsterrad und Job, den er so ganz okay erledigt und so was. Vielleicht überlegt ihr halt auch nochmal, was sind so vielleicht Dinge, die dir gut liegen, wo du eine Leidenschaft dafür hast oder wo du vielleicht auch ein bisschen Talent dafür hast. Keine Ahnung, ist jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt was viel mit Zahlen, ist es eher was Kreatives und so. Weil ich glaube, man muss erst mal auch selber wissen, was sind meine Stärken, was sind meine Stärken.
Ich glaube, so redet man mit neunjährigen, oder? Machst du gern was mit Zahlen. Aber doch nicht mit 25-jährigen. Machst du gern was mit Zahlen? Ja, ich mach gern was mit Zahlen.
Hier steht sogar, ich habe einen Job, den ich ganz gut erledige. Das klingt für mich gar nicht mal so, als wäre der Job das Problem. Vielleicht ist es mehr so ein Problem, dass er in so einem.
Jetzt man denkt ganz kurz, Job ist vielleicht gar nicht das Problem, sondern jetzt kommt vielleicht jetzt die gesellschaftliche Ebene.
Umfeld ist, wo er denkt, jetzt bin ich ein Angestellter, jetzt bin ich ein User oder so. Weißt du? Weil es ist ja schon so ein Gag, der so existiert. Und ich check auch natürlich, wenn jetzt bei jemandem eine Selbstständigkeit funktioniert, dann ist das wahrscheinlich auch so all in all chilliger.
Also Hoss und Topf, Selbstständigkeit, einfach selbstständig werden.
Ich finde, der Hamsterrad ist schon so, also weißt du, was ich meine? Vielleicht denkt ihr so, Alter, ich mache jetzt hier einen 9 to 5. Ich werde es niemals reißen im Leben. Ich bin ein Versager. Vielleicht ist es wirklich für mich fast so, als wäre das mentale das Problem und gar nicht unbedingt das, was er macht.
Ja, der hat noch zu viele Ambitionen.
Ja, vielleicht einfach mal die Let-Them-Theorie lesen.
Genau.
Das sind hier die großen Ratschläge. Geht noch weiter.
Also, wenn er sagt, ich habe einen Job, den ich ganz gut erledige, klingt das für mich nicht so als ein mega toller Job.
Aber ich finde das auch nicht, als wäre das eine extreme Erfüllung.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die Wahrheit ist leider, dass die meisten Leute einen Job machen, der nicht die Übelst Erfüllung ist.
Safe, aber ich würde dann...
Aha, könnte man jetzt vielleicht endlich mal über was Politisches sprechen.
Wenn wir ihnen einen Tipp geben und sagen, frag doch mal vielleicht rum oder guck mal hier und da, dann finde ich, ist das ja nochmal eine Chance halt zu gucken, vielleicht wo sind denn tatsächlich deine Stärken? Weißt du, es macht doch keinen Sinn, es macht doch keinen Sinn, dann weiter in diesem Schlamassel zu bleiben, wenn du jetzt gerade irgendwas arbeitest, wo du eh schon wenig verdienst und so. Also eigentlich, keine Ahnung, es ist all in all nicht so top und du guckst schon nach neuen Jobs, dann vielleicht nochmal, also ich meine, dieses Lernprogrammieren und dann werden krasser Programmierer im Homeoffice und verdienen ganz viel Geld ist natürlich so ein Stereotyp, dass kann natürlich jetzt einer von tausend Schaffters oder sowas, aber ich meine nur, stell dir mal auf, man kann es vielleicht doch mal probieren. Ja. Du denkst so drüber nach und merkst so, ja Digger, ich bin gerade im Personalmanagement, aber eigentlich macht mir das überhaupt gar keinen Spaß. Das und das ist eher mein Ding. Dann hast du zumindest mal einen Anhaltspunkt, wo du vielleicht sagst, ey, wenn ihr mal in eurer Firma was hört, dass sie da den und den suchen, oder du kannst dich abends hinsetzen und siehst halt nochmal wirklich jeden Tag, lernst du eine Stunde irgendwas Neues?
Also ich denke halt drüber nach.
Vielleicht ein Jodel-Diplom machen oder so.
Die sind ja Podcaster und wir auch.
Ja.
Ich war vor einigen Wochen in der Schule meiner mittleren Tochter.
Denn da wurden Eltern eingeladen, damit sie über ihre Berufe reden. Also saß ich da und musste mir was überlegen. Und natürlich kann ich dann sagen, wie es im Fernsehen ist, wie es ist, eine Zeitung zu machen usw. Also ich finde sozusagen Auswege. Aber was würden die beiden über ihre eigenen Berufe sagen?
Ich weiß das nicht.
Lebenshilfe, Podcasts, wir helfen Menschen.
Wir reden doll Zeug.
Ich meine, ich habe gerade noch mein Argument im Sinne von, wir müssen mal virtuelle Politik wagen, versucht mit. Man kann da schon Programme finden, Hauptsache es ist irgendwas. Aber anscheinend braucht man wirklich gar keine Inhalte.
Nein.
Man macht einfach.
Ja und du bekommst ja dann einen Vertrag. Also ich meine, ich war ja angefragt für so eine Opernsendung, hatte ich glaube ich jemals erzählt und da hat man gesagt, na inhaltlich vielleicht doch auch alles ein bisschen zu schwierig. Zu Opernhäusern in Europa, ja, also war selbst Arte doch ein bisschen zu heavy. Ich hätte einfach sagen müssen, ja ich rede doll Zeug 90 Minuten und habe noch einen anderen Idioten gefunden. Gebt mir Geld. Genau. Weil ich meine, das wird ja nicht billig sein. Also Papaplatte ist ja ein YouTuber, der wie wir ja wissen, weil er ja da mit seinem Cutter sich angelegt hatte, zehntausende im Monat macht nur damit, dass irgendwelche Clips nochmal wiederverwertet werden, die er bei Twitch produziert. Das heißt, da ist ja Geld ohne Ende da. Der wird ja nicht da für 1000 Euro setzen, nehme ich an, sondern da werden ja horrende Summen gezahlt. Und ich will das wirklich nochmal hier klar machen. Ich kenne viele Leute, die beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Radio sind und die da sehr anspruchsvolle Formate machen, politischer Natur, kultureller Natur. Und die bekommen alle es mit Budgetkürzungen zu tun. Große Features werden vom Radio nicht weiter gefördert und, und, und. Die werden überall beschnitten und gekürzt. Als ich jetzt gerade eine Anfrage bekam vom Radio, ob ich ein Interview geben könne für über Thomas Bernhard, fragte, sagte ich ja und fragte nach dem Honorar. Und dann sagte man mir, ja, man habe kein Honorar. Und dann habe ich geschrieben, dann spreche ich nicht, denn solange noch solche idiotischen Laber-Podcasts produziert werden, werde ich nicht mal mehr piepkostenlos im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen sagen. Das ist die Situation. Das Geld fließt jetzt an solche Leute. Das passiert jetzt gerade und der Rest teilen sich Giovanni Zarella und Florian Silbereisen.
Wir machen es so. Wir suchen uns. Wir suchen uns einen der nächsten vier KÄS-Termine nächstes Jahr raus und dann versuchen wir das mal genau so. Mal gucken, ob wir das zwei Stunden schaffen.
Stefan, ich hab ja immer so Angst vor dir, vor deinem menschlichen Überschuss, den du dann produzierst und dann uns in die Predoye bringst.
Aber stell dir mal vor, wir bringen nichts mit. Wir reden einfach nur wie in so einem österreichischen Präsidenten-Charz-Wahlkampf.
Nein, unser Anspruch ist ja, wir graben uns tief ein und bringen dann unsere Ergebnisse mit. Ein letzter Clip aus diesem großartigen Beratungsgespräch für Felix, das dann so endet.
Aber trotzdem sitzt er da und denkt so, ja okay, wenn ich es einfach faktisch vergleiche, kacke ich ja gegen die ab. Das kann ja auch einfach in deinem eigenen Kopf sein. So, das weiß man ja.
Im eigenen Kopf ist es halt auch. Es ist nicht auch nicht statistisch zu finden, es ist nur im eigenen Kopf.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig zu wissen, dass es normaler ist, als man denkt.
Ja, schreib mal in die Kommentare, Freund. Tausche ich da mal gern drüber aus, finde ich geil.
Ja.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir wieder zu ein bisschen sexy Tipps. Ich habe schon mal kurz die erste Selle gelesen.
So, ja, das war die schöne Beratung. Also da muss man ja fast mal nachhören, ob es Felix noch gut geht nach so einem Podcast. Dass man da nicht sagt, okay, das hat mir den Rest gegeben dann, was die beiden sagten. Menschliche Emotionen also werden jetzt gerade öffentlich-rechtlich produziert, im Privatfernsehen produziert. Alex Karp kann auch noch ein paar Tränen mit hinzugeben, wenn sie benötigt werden. Und wir haben also ein Publikum, das nur noch so, ja, da raufblickt, wie wir, weiß ich nicht, in den Zoo vielleicht mal gehen und uns die Tierchen ansehen. Aber selbst das wäre eigentlich zu viel gesagt. Da der Mensch ja, wie wir aus der philosophischen Anthropologie wissen, immer nur über oder unter dem Tier stehen kann, ist er nicht ein Tier. Aber wir bekommen jedenfalls ein Publikum da, das nur noch so reflexartig irgendwie auf Emotionen reagiert, auf menschliche Laute und ein rationaler Diskurs ist dann ja auch nicht mehr möglich. Und wir haben das Ganze begonnen damit, dass wir im Handelsblatt-Morning-Briefing hörten, dass Alex Karp ein Interview gegeben hat, in dem er sagte, die Migrationspolitik, der Bundesrepublik, das Schlimmste, was man gemacht hat und jeder, der hier auch nur an Kriminalität denkt, muss sofort ausgewiesen werden. Wer hier nichts verloren hat, muss raus und zwar in den nächsten vier Wochen. Ja, die Realität sieht ja fast schon aus wie bei Alex Karp. Und auch das wird hier nicht einmal in irgendeiner nüchternen Weise vorgebracht, sondern die ARD zu Primetime bringt dann eine Sendung wie Die 100, in der gefragt wird, wie gut werden wir regiert. Dort taucht ein deutscher Adler auf im Deutschlandtrikot und macht Laola Wellen dafür, dass wir uns neu verschulden für die Aufrüstung. Das habe ich aber jetzt alles nicht dabei, sondern ich will direkt an Alex Karp anknüpfend einen einzigen Clip spielen. Und zwar geht es da genau um die Migration, den Umgang mit Menschen, die nach Deutschland wollen oder in Deutschland sind. Und man hat dafür für ein Publikum, das wahrscheinlich schon blöd geworden ist durch all diese anderen Unterhaltungsformate, hat man sich was ausgedacht. Wie machen wir das besonders klar und schön, dass diese Regierung so herrlich arbeitet?
Ja, da sagen sie, oh, und ich sage, gucken wir doch mal auch auf das Thema, wenn es jetzt um gutes und schlechtes Regieren geht. Was ist denn mit Versprechen einhalten? Was hat die Bundesregierung uns versprochen? Und da ging es um die Sorgen der Menschen. Es wäre super, wenn die Nummern 1 bis 68 einmal die Hand heben könnten. Also Nummer 1 bis 68. Das sind, liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu Hause, zwei Drittel Nummer 1 bis 68. Und so viele Menschen haben Anfang des Jahres, also vor der Bundestagswahl gesagt, unser größtes Problem ist die Migration.
Nachdem sie wochenlang nichts anderes im Fernsehen gehört haben, als dass das das größte Problem ist. Ja, wen wundert das? Mich wundert immer nur, dass es nur zwei Drittel sind da eigentlich.
Wir müssen irgendwelche neuen Lösungen bei der Migrationspolitik finden. Der Kanzler.
Und wir sehen ja jetzt die Moderatorin, wie sie auf einem Bett sitzt. Auf einem Hochbett, wie man es aus Flüchtlingsunterkünften kennt.
Klar, und die Bundesregierung haben gesagt, okay, das gehen wir an. Und man muss mal ganz klar sagen, die haben geliefert. Die haben das, was bestellt wurde, geliefert. Und deshalb sitze ich hier oben auf diesem Bett. Weil diese Betten, das ist hier wirklich ein echtes Flüchtlingsbett aus Göttingen, hier aus der Umgebung. Es wird nicht mehr gebraucht. Man kann darauf sitzen und moderieren, weil in immer mehr Gemeinden, in immer mehr Städten, diese Betten abgebaut werden. Weil nämlich die Zahl der Asyl...
Ich muss nur sagen, das Publikum, das da ja steht, ist erwachsen. Aber sie spricht ja wie zu Dreijährigen. Das ist auch eine interessante Haltung, die die ARD zugebracht hat. Eigenen Klientel hat.
Erstanträge zurückgegangen sind. Sie haben den Kanzler in der Arena gehört und seine Zahlen stimmen auch mit unseren überein. Wir hatten, wenn man das vergleicht, Januar bis Oktober im vorherigen Jahr 217.000 Erstanträge. Mittlerweile ist das Ganze nur noch halbiert bei 106.000. Er hat gesagt, jetzt gibt es auch noch eine neue EU-Politik. Es ist aber das, was die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung sich gewünscht hat, was sie gelöst haben wollte als Problem. Und Merz und seine Regierung sind das angegangen und haben im Ergebnis plötzlich hier Betten, die abgebaut werden. Und deshalb helfen sie bitte einmal mit. Hier stehen ja noch mehr Betten. Könnten sie einmal da vorne mit anpacken. Es ist so schön, sich darauf aufzuschützen. Aber nein, einmal bitte unten anfassen, oben fixieren und dann einmal raustragen. Denn tatsächlich, in immer mehr Gemeinden können die Betten abgebaut werden und weniger Betten. Heißt auch, die Turnhallen, die können wieder genutzt werden. Dankeschön an unsere Helferinnen und Helfer, da sie kennen solche Schlagzeilen. Überall aus der Republik, Sporthalle wieder frei.
Hurra, wir schieben ab und das ganze Volk packt mit an.
Ja, schlimm.
Assoziationen sind alle da, müssen nicht benannt werden, hier an dieser Stelle. So haben wir jetzt den Umgang mit den Menschen. Die menschlichen Emotionen werden noch mal so erregt und angeregt. Erzählen tut man es wie für kleine Kinder. Die Politik teilt sich irgendwo auf zwischen Abschiebung und KI von Alex Karp. Das ist die Situation, in der wir sind und daneben labern die Podcasts uns voll und geben der KI noch ein paar menschliche Rede mit.
Wir schreiben das alles mal in die Kommis, wie wir das finden. Ich will zum Ende einen kleinen Clip noch spielen, denn der Bayerische Rundfunk hat für mich stellvertretend nachgefragt, wie steht es eigentlich um Friedrich Merz Familienpolitik, wo doch Stefan Schulz vor einem Jahr die 4.000 Euro Spende bei Ein Herz für Kinder um einen Euro übertrumpft hat mit der Ansage, damit mache ich mehr Familienpolitik als Friedrich Merz. Friedrich Merz erklärt hier kurz seine familienpolitischen Erfolge.
Ich bin seit 1998 der erste Bundeskanzler, der eigene Kinder hat und das brächt auch mein politisches Arbeiten.
Ah, interessant. Und wie äußert sich das? Was haben Sie denn in Ihrer bisherigen Amtszeit für Kinder schon politisch so umgesetzt?
Ich bin seit 1998 der erste Bundeskanzler, der wieder Kinder hat.
Ja, verstanden. Das haben Sie schon gesagt. Aber alles, was sich die Regierung für Kinder und Familien im Koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen hat, ist derzeit nicht einmal im Gespräch.
Ich bin der erste in diesem Amt seit 1998, der eigene Kinder hat.
Ah, okay, cool. Jetzt noch mal mit Musik unterlegt. Aber was genau machen Sie denn konkret mehr für Kinder als die anderen Kanzler seit 1998? Okay, vielen Dank fürs Gespräch, Herr Merz. Und damit zurück nach München.
Ja, ich habe gegen die ganze Bundesregierung gewonnen.
Ich gratuliere dir, aber es ist ein trauriger Sieg, sagen wir so.
Diesmal machen wir keinen Wettkampf draus, sondern es gab ja beim Jahres, ihr habt eine Weihnachtsgala gemacht in Hamburg.
Ja.
Der Saal hat gesammelt. Helena Steinaus hat das Geld persönlich entgegen genommen. Ich nenne jetzt keine Summe, aber ich habe John Phillips Kindlers Gang um ein Euro wieder übertroffen mit meiner diesjährigen Weihnachtsspende. Ich möchte wieder der Gewinner sein für Sie.
Wir werden auch noch mal für Helenas Verein im nächsten Podcast.
Ja, wir haben ein Großwort von Helena beim nächsten Podcast.
Sie wird uns einen kleinen Clip unsenden mit einem Großwort und einem Spendenaufruf für ihren Verein Sanktionsfrei. So ist es. Damit bedanken wir uns ganz herzlich und hören uns dann noch mal Ende des Monats.
So ist es.
Bis bald.